What are you eating over there and directly into the microphone?
What is it?
This is like fisherman's friend.
She'll be illegal tomorrow.
We're live.
All right.
Fisherman's friend.
That's like,
let's like a gross cough drop.
Right?
But you don't feel like doing,
when I lecture a lot and you have to speak in a loud voice for a long time,
sometime I go to waste.
My throat is killing me.
I take one of these things.
I don't fucking feel anything for 20 minutes.
He's like anesthesia or something.
It's insane.
Interesting.
I'll have to look into it,
but they taste like shit,
right?
Yeah.
But it's so bad that it's beyond tasting good or bad.
It's like,
it's a whole lot.
The medicine something girls.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by carbonite.
Carbonite is a,
uh,
a backup option where he can back up all your data and information online.
Small businesses,
uh,
regular folks like you or I that have a lot of shit that you're trying to back
up.
It's really simple.
Proposals,
contracts,
invoices,
contact lists,
all essential stuff for running your businesses.
Uploading it online is a nice,
safe,
easy way to make sure it's always there.
Um,
carbonite is available for all computers.
It's a,
it works on everything and when you have carbon that you'll never have to worry
about losing your computer files,
no matter how many computers your business has or where they're located.
Carbonite backs up your files to the cloud securely,
automatically and continually,
which is a very nice thing if you're a guy like me that's always like,
yeah,
I got to remember to back that up.
I don't back shit up.
I think I'm going to back it up.
I know I'm going to back it up and it never gets done.
But this way it does it easily.
It does it automatically and you don't have to think too much about it keeps
your files safe without any hassle for you or your employees and it's
affordable.
We use carbonite here on the podcast and you could try it to use the offer code,
J r e for a free trial,
no credit card required plus two free bonus months with your subscription.
So that's carbonite.com and the offer code is j r e s go to carbonite.com and
get your freak on.
Pack Your Shit Up,
son.
Take it seriously.
Okay,
please.
We also brought to you by stamps.com stamps.com is a nice,
easy way for you to send things through the mail without having gone to go to
the post office in way shit you have,
you weigh it at home,
they provide you the digital scale.
You enter in the information,
you computer,
print up the actual postage on a printer,
slap it on the box and it's gone.
As soon as the mailman comes handed to him,
you don't have to deal with any of the nonsense of going to an actual post
office.
Getting in the actual line and dealing with an actual employee that doesn't
actually give a fuck what you're sending.
It doesn't really want to talk to you and you're,
you're being annoying,
man.
If I was working at the post office and this asshole came in with 36 boxes of
different sizes,
I was like,
oh,
how boring.
But this way you can do it all at home and with this no risk trial,
use the Como,
the Promo Code j r e you get $110 bonus offer,
which includes the digital scale and up to $55 of free postage.
All of it again could be done through your home computer.
You just hand the boxes to the post man when he comes and your dignity,
dignity,
done.
That's it.
You don't have to deal with any more nonsense.
So use the code word J,
r E.
Click on the microphone,
the old school,
the microphone in the upper right hand corner and enter it in that code for your
$110 special bonus offer.
We're also brought to you by on it.
That's o,
n n I t.com o,
n n,
I t and we just started carrying these new of Zombie bells.
These are the latest and greatest of the primal bell type series.
We started with the ones who are just apes with gorillas and chimps and,
uh,
orangutans.
Now how we're monkeys.
But now we've expanded into the supernatural and we have actual Zombie artwork
that was created by the same guy who did the,
uh,
the chimp's named Stevens Shubin Junior,
very talented artists,
and he created the gorilla,
the chimps and monkeys and all these pretty Badass zombies.
So I feel like me,
and you're obsessed with the walking dead.
These are an excellent way to get your workout on and have a little fun with it
while you're at it.
They're all three d balance,
so they're all,
um,
they're,
they're a weighted and balanced perfectly for exercise,
not just for looks.
We made sure that they're,
they're designed,
they're designed sort of meshed well with the actual idea of using them.
I mean,
it's cool that they look cool and everything like that,
but you really want to be able to work out with them so you can work out with
them just as easy as you can with a regular kettle bell.
We also sell battle ropes,
weight vest,
steel,
maces,
lots of supplements.
We've got all sorts of new shit that's just come in,
uh,
including digestive enzymes and on at one 80 on at one 80 is uh,
the idea said when you travel or when you go out and get your drink,
you drink on you,
it's,
it's nice to have something that can replenish all the nutrients in your body in
one little step to zip one of these little packets and toss it into a glass of
water.
It has,
um,
a lot of different things that we,
it combines a neurotransmitter support of Alpha brain,
the best adaptogens from shroom tech sport,
some five HTP from new mood and some minerals for the immune system.
And these nutrients play a key role in supporting multiple body systems for
recovery from stress.
Like a lot of what you're,
you're,
if you,
if you get hung over or if you fly that terrible feeling that you have,
a lot of that is just being dehydrated.
A lot of that is just lacking water and nutrients and something like one 80 can
really help you recover from that shit.
Son.
Use the code word,
j.
R.
E No Rogan God.
I need one code.
He'd want to go for everything.
I'm trying to fuck every commercial up on purpose just so they eventually you're
forced to give me one code.
You use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements.
Boom,
Sherlock,
lock,
boom.
Danieli Bolelli and Dan Carlin.
You're here,
ladies and gentlemen.
This shit could get epic
experience.
[inaudible] the two guys that have freaked me out,
the stories of the past.
It's you two gentlemen.
So what we do with a pleasure for out of all the years of listening to podcasts
and talking to you guys on the podcast,
you are without a doubt these the two men who have freaked me out the most.
You would that crazy story about the bodies on the stakes.
Uh,
was it in Persia or Rome?
What was the story?
I think I told you have to whine about it.
Of course in Pailin and all the fun stuff that goes with it.
Then the other one was about the end of Spartacus rebellion where they crucify
some 5,000 people on the road between Naples and Rome.
That was it.
Yeah,
that's dark.
That would be at [inaudible] very,
she would take that road on those days.
Could you even imagine just wa I mean,
just the amount,
the idea,
I mean,
how many miles is that?
What?
It's 5,000 people.
How far did they space them out?
Sit about a hundred miles,
something like that.
Since he like a hundred miles of crucified.
Bonnie's every so many steps.
One more,
you know,
what does that a blink in terms of actual time on this planet?
Just a blink ago.
Like these same things that we go to school with and go to the supermarket with
these same humans are capable of that darkest of dark days from your podcast and
from Danielle.
He's,
I think,
um,
I,
uh,
the understanding of how easy we got it.
It's really cemented home.
You know,
your,
your stories.
Some of the stories,
like especially,
uh,
one of the ones that I really enjoyed recently is the Martin Luther Tale,
the tale of Lutheranism and the Anabaptist and the city of Munster and
Fascinating Waco on a huge scale.
Fascinating,
fascinating stuff.
And again,
not that long ago,
man,
1500 something.
What was it?
Oh,
a guy like that could arise today too.
And today,
I mean,
they still make those kinds of people.
Yeah,
yeah,
they do.
We do.
You know,
what is it about people that fall for that shit?
I mean,
it's just,
it's,
there's a sucker born every minute,
right?
What is the flaw in humans that were willing to believe people that are,
that fucking Nutso might take?
He's,
uh,
the appeal of authority.
That's why they eat lots of the ward,
uh,
gain an audience is because most people are very secure.
Where most people like a father figure to tell them,
I got it under control.
I'm the strong man in charge.
I can take care of business,
look at me.
And I think there's an appeal of people who have that day shoes.
They like dictators they at that's party is likely oversimplified.
But I think there's a part of it.
There's also a thing where I think people really terribly want to be a part of a
group.
Oh yeah.
Like very,
very much so.
And the more extreme,
their devotion to that group is
sometimes the more rewarding.
The actual experience of being in the group as it means something special to be
a part of this wacky group of crazy fucks.
It's willing to murder people.
Like it's almost like this extra charge of being alive that's missing from a lot
of people's lives.
I think that being involved in a court or,
and you know,
so any sort of crazy wild,
rebellious group that's doing dangerous things,
it's like it's almost to fill a void that's left in in human beings that we've
sort of like,
there's these echoes of our primal days that are still just lingering around in
our DNA looking to be played upon with the right harp note.
You know,
I think there's almost two.
When you think about like a Hitler,
there's some wonderful film.
You can see if Hitler with crowds on the street and you can see the look in the
people's eyes and they look like they're seeing a movie star and the decent,
just want to get a little touch.
Maybe my hand will touch his fingers and,
and,
and you just,
you think to yourself,
Hitler as a celebrity type figure.
But there's that same thing about,
about,
because you're famous because I don't even know how,
I've never understood this celebrity thing where people just get dumb a,
but it's the same sort of the look in the eyes and it's like seeing Elvis and
instead it's Hitler.
Yeah.
I think you're onto something there for sure.
Because there's something about the,
the ultimate celebrity experience,
like meeting a guy like Obama or meeting,
you know,
and any,
any world leader type care there would be so overwhelming.
Just the presence of that person.
Now think about this all happening at a time when I was fucking really hard to
get a book,
you know,
really hard to be properly educated and no alternative media sources that we,
we faced the day,
you know,
Pete goof on alternative media,
all you want online and some of it as much deserve.
But the one thing these guys do is they'll cover all kinds of fringe shit and
that'll be their headline news.
You know,
like I go to salon and people excuse accused salon of being like too left wing
and to,
you know,
but there's some smart people that are pushing it that way.
What I like,
what they're doing is that they're front news is like,
it's not like the front news that you're going to get on CNN.
It's front news about,
you know,
like a gay and lesbian rights and,
and things in the workplace and you know,
what,
what politicians said about,
you know,
what race that was deplorable and all that stuff's like front row shit.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's really,
really lefty.
Very,
very lefty.
But that's important too.
Like it's,
it's important to have like a,
a balance out of super ultra sensitive to balance out the fucking savages of the
15 hundreds of,
they're still rolling around in our DNA.
You know,
you need someone out there on the fringes of supersensitive progressive behavior
just to try to like give us a better medium.
Give us a better baseline.
Well,
let me,
and let me bring it back to that.
That monster podcast we talked about.
One of the sub themes in that was whether or not you remember that the whole
question of whether or not
regular people should be able to read the Bible for themselves.
And this goes to what you said about salon or all these alternative media sites
because the prime minister in Great Britain over all these Snowden leaks and
what the Guardian has done was talking about,
you know,
maybe we should dial this back.
Maybe it's time for some press restrictions.
In other words,
maybe it's,
maybe this is too darn dangerous that you're getting to read all this stuff and
we don't have a choke point to shut it down because in the regular media,
whether it was ABC,
CBS,
NBC,
The Washington Post it,
there are choke points where you know,
these people literally just pick up the red phone to the editor of the
Washington Post and say,
let's talk about this story you're thinking about running.
That's a great choke point when you have the media as diversified as it is now,
all those choke points go away,
and the David Cameron's and all these people miss the choke points and there's
people like that,
Glenn Greenwald or Edward Snowden in a lesser extent because he's on the run and
hiding.
That becomes huge celebrities because of information that they released to
people like Greenwald,
even though I know they harass him and they've harassed his boyfriend.
He detained his boyfriend in England and,
but the bottom line is that guy became super famous because of this.
So it's a positive thing.
Well,
think of how he changed the world.
I mean,
I had a lot of people right when the story broke say,
this is no big deal.
Nothing.
We haven't heard,
all this kind of stuff.
They're not saying that now.
Even even John Kerry,
the president,
all these people have come out and said things that,
oh,
maybe we shouldn't be doing this.
Maybe we should be having this discussion.
It's really changed the world.
All this stuff we're talking about now with the NSA,
that's all Edward Snowden stuff.
Yeah.
It's amazing that that one guy can have that kind of impact and in the future
when they look back on today,
and I think historically he's getting swept under the rug and what he's done and
the impact of it is just sort of getting ignored by the media and more and more
they'd paint him as this controversial figure.
You know,
more and more they paint him as this guy on the run from the NSA,
but there's no supportive him.
Like in anything mainstream.
Right.
There's no support of what he did or who he is,
or no,
there's no call to action for the government to release this guy that he's
actually a patriot,
that he's actually is looking out for the true American way and is exposing
people to people.
Not the America,
but people in America.
I that I'm making a huge mistake and they're doing it for the name of America
and whether or not they think it's right or wrong,
ultimately we don't think it's right.
And ultimately finding out about it pissed the entire world off.
That's the facts.
So if the government was really representing the people,
they would look at it in terms of like widow,
all the intelligent people who've reviewed this thing.
Yeah.
It's a travesty.
It's a fuckup.
It's,
it's anti-American.
The idea of is ridiculous.
And the idea,
this is the only way you can control security is by spying on every fucking
person within the terrorists.
Have one.
I mean that's,
that's a victory because that's terror for everybody.
That's no privacy.
That's weirdness.
That's employees like Snowden,
who they kept going on and on about.
He failed high school,
high school dropout,
high school,
drop out.
That could read my email,
man.
High school dropout.
That just makes you look worse.
You pass code to that high school,
drop out.
What the fuck?
Why you goofing on him?
You hired him,
you know it's ridiculous.
You fucking hired that guy to watch everybody's mean.
How you know you were talking about one person,
just one guy,
but think about how much that same attitude scares the government.
One of their many,
many,
many thousands of workers was able to do that.
That's scary on the whole opposite side.
You know what it is too.
I think we're dealing with a bit of a,
and this is kind of gets them a little off the hook.
I think you have a bubble mentality in all the,
I mean in life you have them in professions.
I mean,
scientists get it,
unions get it,
bureaucracies get it,
the army gets it,
the police gets it.
Where where people get promoted.
These guys all get promoted to the top NSA positions because they're better at
spying.
They figure out better ways to get around defenses and they don't get promoted
to that special room where there's five or six of them making policy because
they did a better job of finding a fourth amendment that doesn't let them spy.
So when they're in the room,
they all see the world the same way.
So you tend,
and this happens,
like I said,
in every profession,
they tend to push each other forward because there's no devil's advocate there
saying,
wait a minute,
maybe we shouldn't use every power we have to spy as much as we can to those
people.
You see these NSA guys testifying in front of Congress and they don't even hide
how mad they are at us,
how mad they are that this is even known how mad that they have to be there,
how mad you're questioning them.
And it's because there's nobody in the room saying,
guys,
we shouldn't do this.
And,
and really to be honest,
there is no obvious line where you should call the dogs off.
You know where you should say,
hey,
maybe this is okay,
but that's not okay.
That does not happen.
They talk about the fourth amendment,
but then the other guy goes,
well,
we're not really violating the fourth amendment.
If we just take everybody's trash at Cannes and we keep it in a storage locker
with their name on it,
we're only violating it if we actually like search through their trash,
which we'll do later if we have to,
and then then everything's on the kosher up and up.
If j Edgar Hoover wants to search Joe Rogan's trash for evidence of illegal
activity,
you're going to have to send a physical agent out there to do that.
Now we just collect the trash on trash day,
bring it to the NSA headquarters,
dump it in there,
and we'll sift through it later if we have to.
Yeah,
they could essentially tuning on anybody anywhere in the world now with a flip
of a switch and that kind of power is awesome.
If you guys are like super enlightened monks that are designed to save the
world,
but he was going again,
right,
exactly.
That you're a regular person,
you can't have that kind of juice.
Regular person just can't have autonomy over all these people's information.
What if Richard Nixon had it?
That's what I'll just say.
And you think you're not going to get another one of those dude.
What if Dick Cheney had it?
He did have it.
Did he have it?
Yeah.
You think so?
Absolutely.
He,
he,
he put it into place,
man.
So they were everybody's emails as far back.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a book called the 1% doctrine where they talk about how after the nine
11 attacks the rule that they decided and mainly because of Dick Cheney to
operate under was it,
there's even a 1% chance of another nine 11 happening.
Anything is fair.
You can do anything to justify it.
And I think what their attitude was is on,
you know,
nine 12 2002 everybody would've said,
oh yeah,
okay.
Whatever it takes,
man.
Don't let that happen again when it was still fresh in our mind.
Yeah.
There was a weird moment after nine 11 where I remember driving to school or to
work rather.
And I'm trying to school as I was driving,
as I was driving to,
uh,
to work.
Uh,
it was early in the morning and all the computers were going and everybody had a
flag on the car.
Everybody had it.
And it was weird.
It was a weird feeling.
It was,
it wasn't just a,
it was like everybody was reminding everyone.
How long did that last two,
cause I'm thinking,
I just said 2002 it,
everyone's been equipped to handle it.
You know,
the nine 11 attacks happened in 2001 but a year later that was still an open
wound.
And so how long,
how,
when do you think,
if you had to guess,
when did it start to wear off?
And we started to normalize.
I mean New York City is exempt because I don't think they ever renormalize but
for the rest of the country.
How long do you think it took to get over that PTSD?
I think it took a few years.
Yeah,
two or three years,
something like that.
I give you even more like butch side cause I mean bushmeat and reelected made no
fucking sense under any point of view other than part of the nine 11 boosts that
he got for awhile.
It was also the real problem with the voting machines.
There's a real yeah,
that will openly reported problems with those Diebold machines and
candidate he ran against.
That's always the first [inaudible].
If you're running against John F.
Kennedy,
you lose that election but you're not,
you're running against the guy.
He's just go,
Oh really?
That's my option.
And that's what kills you.
Yeah.
Well in a lot of people felt like the,
the Al Gore election that got pushed in the office in the front.
That was a weird one too.
That was a weird one.
There's so much fuckery involved in voting man.
Like real open fuckery that should be like really it's treason,
it's treasonous behavior and these people openly do it in order to help their
candidates.
When mean it's one of the most unamerican things of all time manipulating the
vote.
I think somebody who's who was a political operative would say to you that it's
one of the most American time because it's been going on.
I mean,
you know,
George Washington's giving hard cider to people,
when they come to his little parties to get,
I mean this is the problem is,
is that I,
and we've talked about this before,
I think there's a certain amount of this that a healthy society and a healthy
political system can suck up and still be okay.
There's a certain tipping point where you're not that healthy anymore and what
was okay before is not suck up a bubble anymore.
You've got Bible.
I love that.
Well,
it also begs the question,
all of this stuff begs the question like,
first of all,
everyone's favorite argument is if you have to hide,
then what are you worried about?
And it's not that what,
what,
what it is is first of all,
why do you need so much information and what,
what have you done that have made so many people so angry that you have to check
everyone's email?
Like,
what is the actual cause of all this that never gets addressed.
Like whenever we're talking about how this group hates us of that group hates us
and this group is playing.
Why?
What did we,
what did I want to take?
I want to go with we do.
I want to go with what you said that the,
if you have nothing to hide,
because I was just,
I was trying to get a show up before I came here and I failed miserably.
But one of the things I was going to talk about,
did you see that story?
The lawsuit filed from that incident in New Mexico with the driver who didn't do
the full stop leaving Walmart.
You saw it,
right?
Right.
So,
so the police pulled him over for,
for California stopping the stop sign.
Decide that he looks like he's clenching his bud hawks in a weird way,
and this is the part I love,
goes to a judge and says to the judge,
while this guy is sitting on the side of the road,
he's clenching his buttocks.
In a weird way.
I think we have somebody trying to hide drugs in there.
And the judge goes,
I guess judging from the story,
yeah,
that would be probable cause.
So they take this guy to a doctor who refuses to do with the police officer's
rescue.
So they got to go to another doctor,
14 hours of anal cavity searches,
enemas.
They sedated him and did a colonoscopy.
They examined his stuff right in front of him.
14 hours,
found nothing,
x rate him multiple times,
found nothing.
And then apparently send him a $6,000 bill for the procedure.
So when you say,
what have you got to hide if,
unless you're Heidi,
that's what can happen to you if [inaudible] not just that.
What I love is the police department spokesman said,
we didn't do anything wrong.
This is policy.
And we had a judge sign off on it.
So when you say if you have nothing to hide,
what do you care?
This guy had nothing to hide.
And that happened to him.
Clearly did because he was [inaudible] away.
I know,
but now,
now if that story's true and the and the lawsuit claims witnesses and all this
kind of stuff and the police officer's think nothing was wrong there,
that's what happens to you when you get rid of these protections that keep you
from being searched willy nilly or anything like that.
If after a story like that,
everyone in the ward was going to be stopped by the police,
he's going to claim she's in weird way.
Just the fear of this story.
It's like,
Oh shit.
Little Dasko pinned on people that are but freaks and that's what they're into.
They're into cops checking them out and their skies treasures up there.
Put secrets up there.
I didn't mean to,
I didn't mean to take the conversation in that direction.
It's a great direction.
It's hilarious.
It's,
it's,
well,
it's fucked up that if you search,
someone's asked for 14 hours and there's nothing up there.
That guy should be able to search your for 28 that should be the rule.
He should be able to throw firecrackers in there and then mean,
come on man.
He checked his ass for no reason.
Like you owe him something.
What bothers
me about that is that there's no penalty that actually affects the people who
did this.
In other words at this guy wins is big lawsuit against them.
That's the taxpayers who are going to pay that.
The people who did it don't suffer at all.
Yeah.
Like someone falsely accusing someone of murder or theft or any crime like that.
It almost should be worth just as much if you know,
if you set a guy up for murder and you know he didn't really do it,
it should be worth almost as much as like murdering somebody.
They're talking about that with these podcasts,
troll lawsuits and everything to change the sh the law that they're working on
in DC would do.
Some of that would put like some of the onus on these people who say these
things and if you lose your case all of a sudden you're the one responsible for
the day.
In other words,
something story.
Yeah.
Tell that story.
I don't know the full extent of it.
From what I understand.
Someone out there has a patent says they have a pet.
It says they have a patent on,
I'm in a very,
very broadly paraphrase this.
I think it was putting something up in serial form on the Internet.
So essentially it'd be like every podcast,
every youtube channel,
every everything.
We invented that.
Yeah,
you owe us money.
The idea is ridiculous.
Like if you have the Bolelli blog and you decide to number them,
either you're violating a patent.
I obviously I might be way off with this,
but he sent some,
or the company had a already won.
They had beaten,
um,
on a different thing though.
A different thing.
Yeah.
Apple on another patent style lawsuits,
which may or may not have been more worthy,
but this one is a strange because he's targeting podcasters and so a,
it's a big
got,
the whole goal is to get you to talk to the old shakedown though,
where they essentially say,
we're not going to get,
you know,
you,
you stole our technology,
but it's fine.
Just give us $1,000 a month and nobody gets hurt that much.
Oh,
I'm sure it was.
Talk to your friend Adam Corolla.
He got a letter.
Yeah.
Well that's ridiculous.
You know,
the idea that you could patent putting things up and serialized form on the
Internet,
it's like 1994 or something or whenever they claim to have it done.
It's what people have always done.
I mean,
we put everything up and serialized form.
Can you imagine if someone allowed them to do that with television shows?
You can never number episodes anymore.
It's the stupidest idea of all time.
Like the idea that you could control that
but see you,
but it's not stupid if you're them and the lawyers and everything because that
thing that they're working on in DC isn't there yet.
You take a shot,
right.
You know,
you take a shot and you see what happens.
There's no downside.
Yeah,
I could see that.
I could see it from their point of view,
from a strictly business.
Sure.
As they build clock,
we're playing within the rules.
These are the rules and this is how you get paid.
Right.
But I think that ultimately we're going to have to agree on something that makes
a lot more sense.
Because you know you can't get money for nothing from people and that's money
for nothing.
You're not contributing anything.
If you really,
you can get money for nothing for people.
I'm of the totally,
I think we do that all the time that well,
we shouldn't [inaudible] can't get money for nothing.
I'm talking about the ideal scenario.
Okay.
Yeah.
We let's make that clear.
People get something for nothing,
right?
I mean,
I think we're,
we're,
we're going to have a real problem in this country no matter what.
As long as our financial systems remains so vague and is,
it fluctuates,
it goes up and down.
Today,
the Dow crash tomorrow the Dow rises.
Like if,
as long as that's a possibility,
like how could you ever have anything stable ever when your entire,
the entire foundation of your economy is by nature fluctuating daily by nature,
up and down.
So much so that you have to close business at a certain time.
Stop fucking trading.
You have to blow whistle often.
Say No more decisions no more.
No,
you got to stop.
We have to control this economy.
We have to allow chaos.
Only an eight hour bursts and when those bursts are over,
we have to
literally shut down how many trades there would be the what,
the second the market opens when they've had a whole night to digest stuff.
Okay,
first thing in the morning,
it's billions of dollars.
We got to get this trade in before because everybody will beat us to it.
And can you imagine what the market would do,
you know,
on opening now.
Now in the old days,
that's how it was,
but now with the digital trading all in one sec,
there'd be 10 bazillion trades in a second and a half.
What's his stream?
Dia?
The idea that you could only make transactions during the various,
yeah,
it is.
Especially in a global economy when the people in Japan are going,
so we can only trade on American things when we're asleep at night,
I don't under,
yeah,
it's stupid.
It's stupid.
But if they went 24 hours,
people would just take fucking Adderall and just hit it hard.
And people be dying of lack of sleep.
That's right.
Way More than starcraft.
All those people that are dying from playing starcraft.
Yeah.
Well that's not even for real money.
You know,
you play the economy,
you're playing for real money,
but can you,
what do you do?
Like can you day trade in the middle of the night or do you have to do it during
stock market hours?
I think it just stoked.
No,
I think you can set up trades to be,
to be enacted at the market open or whatnot.
She can't just ride the wave and go up and down sell and buy.
I don't think so.
Unless you're doing it.
Maybe on Tokyo time,
maybe you could do the Tokyo Stock Exchange.
They have a different stock,
real addict when you go,
Oh man,
the u s market close.
Where can I play?
Tokyo is just coming alive.
Yeah.
It's,
it is like an addiction.
I really truly believe it.
I don't think it's possible that it couldn't be.
When you're gambling and you're,
you mean essentially the stock market has a lot of gambles.
Yeah.
Especially the way some of these people play it.
It's one thing to say is I want to buy Coca Cola and sell it in 25 years.
So the other thing when you go by
Coca Cola and sell it in 20 seconds,
and even if you're right,
like if you say no,
look,
it seems like a gamble to you because you're uneducated,
but I in fact are,
I'm very educated on this and it's,
it's,
it's more of a calculated risk,
but the reward to risk ratio is very high,
a lot of variables,
but they've got to show the Gambler,
I'll show you on paper,
we,
you know,
we've profited,
x amount of years in a row.
This is not nearly as unstable as you like thinking this,
but part of their charge is the fact that it is a little,
so 2008 happens every now and then or a fucking,
everybody's scrambling and
no one's got a chair and the music just shut off.
What I love about that is when they show you,
you go to the financial advisor's office and they always show you the
historical,
the way these things are performed historically,
and it's always,
the graph starts right after the last terrible crash.
You just go,
well what about,
what about the depression?
Well,
the,
we,
you know,
the depression was an unusual situation that'll never happen again.
And I think today they must start it from like last week.
Don't you think historically the performance in the last seven day period,
we don't know.
It's,
I think the idea of trying to control an entire global economy like that,
it's preposterous.
It's doesn't make any sense.
I don't understand it at all.
And the people that understand it,
I've tried to comfort me and the shore me that it does in fact make good sense.
Right?
And if that's not scary enough,
then you get the collusion of government and we are to call them.
You were,
I mean,
when you think about defended,
there are no laws against the fact that if you have worked for some companies
who can pick up a government job overseeing those,
the workings self,
those very column bunnies or vice versa,
you are in government first and the second you're don,
you can pick up your vice president position in one of the companies that you
just finished benefiting.
That's beyond pervert.
So transparent.
It's one of the ways that they've said our society could go down though and
other societies have throughout history,
is that sometimes they just get too complex to manage and you can ride that wave
sometimes until something bad happens.
But a perfect example is,
I mean a lot of people said that the great depression happened because the what
was going on in the financial system,
overwhelmed people's ability to understand and,
and react and compensate for things.
And I remember people saying,
well,
we'll never have another great depression because we're so on top of things now.
Yeah.
But we have new variables that we don't understand that somebody in the future
is going to say they were such idiots way back there in the early 21st century
will me as a barely educated fool,
what I,
when I look at exactly how everything has fluctuated in Ra,
you know the,
the crash in 2008 and I'll use it makes zero sense because as a fool I look at
it and I go,
look at this,
there's the same amount of people.
There's the same amount of metal,
it's the same amount of concrete,
the same amount of plastic,
same amount of material things no one has produced or taken away anything from
the pile of humanities creations and yet all of a sudden everyone's broke.
Like all of a sudden everything fell apart and people who were prospering just a
week ago are no longer prospering.
When I look at something like that,
I have to feel like,
okay,
these guys are obviously far smarter than I and they're running the system.
So either it's rigged as fuck and someone just extracted a shitload of money out
of the system and did it under the guise of a crash or people were way fucking
dumber than I give them credit.
It's one of those two things.
And I have,
I feel like when a guy like that,
that a,
that cat from New York that ripped everybody off in the Ponzi scheme,
the old dude was this made off Brady made off when a cat like Bernie made off
comes along and rob so many people,
I have to go,
wait a minute,
a minute,
wait a minute.
So no one knows how this thing works.
Well,
but I mean look,
I mean it,
it's,
it's not that hard to understand when people are playing with things that aren't
real,
but selling it for real money and then you're counting that as something that
you don't.
For example,
we take these toxic assets,
right?
It's not as hard to understand as people suggest.
Cause let's say I put you in a house you can't afford and and all the evidence
shows you can't afford it,
then I wouldn't have given it to you 20 years ago.
And then I take a bunch of people like you and I take all of your bad things
that you're never going to be paid and paying back.
And I bundle it into something and then I sell that to someone else based on the
value that isn't really there because none of you can really pay it back and
then you say,
well I'm worth this much money.
I own these assets and they're worth as much money.
And then those assets collapse and all of a sudden you looked like you had $50
million in your asset tree of,
of of stuff and all of a sudden you don't,
you bought something that was worth nothing.
And so all that money that you had on paper just disappeared overnight because
it wasn't real to begin with.
Wasn't weren't there banks during this crisis that we're actually banking on?
Things falling apart.
Yes.
Hedging.
Yeah,
exactly.
So Ho profiting off of it.
Falling apart post to be a risk management diversification tool.
Jesus Christ.
That's a great way of saying
using the proper terminology that or write that down cause that's a brilliant
way of fucking someone in the US.
This is a risk management,
not a risk management for you or risk management for them.
How did they describe risk risk management diversification tool.
That is God damn hilarious.
It's the greatest way the cops in New Mexico said,
that's too the guy searching your cavity is a risk management.
I'm actually writing that down because it's so beautiful.
I think you use that for all kinds of,
they use it in the MMA color commentary.
Him throwing that punch that way as a risk management diversification.
If anybody hears that though,
if I pretended that I actually came up with it on my own,
I would get shit.
All the financial advisors who've watched the MMA would be going,
now he's talking,
if I'm saying it now I have to say it as a inside joke.
Wink,
wink,
risk management,
diversification tool.
That's how we're fucking you be able to fold.
That's hilarious.
That's a brilliant way of putting it.
I'm out.
Then I'm out of it,
but just the idea that that could be legal,
that you could be loaning people money,
setting up loans,
and also gambling on the fact that you're,
you will profit if those loans,
if they default on those,
look,
we know you can't afford this mortgage,
but don't worry.
If you can't pay it,
you'll be taken out of your house and we'll win on this other side over here.
That's my point as like an uneducated fool.
When I look at that system,
I go,
well,
obviously they set it up so they can extract money.
That's the only way it makes sense.
If you have the same amount of people,
you have the same amount of knowledge,
you have the same amount of items and yet all of a sudden everything fell apart.
Somebody fucked you.
Okay.
They just did it in a way that's legal.
You know what I mean?
Banks,
I have to tell your story because this is too crazy.
I remember when I went from incomes to one
after my wife died and every single,
and so I applied for the,
um,
I forgot what they call it,
loan modification,
right.
It's like,
oh,
conditions of change.
You can modify the loan to help somebody stay in the house.
All that.
Right.
So I got two letters from the bank in the same day,
one eye open and he say,
we can't give you the loan modification because you make too much money.
They are doing too well you don't need it.
I opened the next latter.
He said,
we can give you a loan modification because there's no hope.
You can keep the house,
you'll make too little money.
There's just no way.
What the fuck did you talk to each other?
At least it's like er,
the same department.
You're said really this is what it's about.
They just have,
I bet probably like patent excuses,
especially when they feel like you're probably going to lose the house to their
goodwill.
Just snatch up his house.
This is where it gets better.
I knew somebody was hooking up with the people who own the loan.
So through somebody would know somebody who know somebody.
We got to the president of the company like,
Hey man,
can you do something?
Is it something that we can work with and stuff?
I kid you not.
The guy sent back the word,
give me 20,000 under the table and I can make it.
I can make it happen.
Oh my God.
He asked for a bribe.
Yeah,
I told her shit.
And if he's doing that with me,
I'm imagining that's barely a regular business.
Right.
Amazing.
But you know,
there's no paper trail so you know you can prove it.
So you'd have to come up with 20 cash.
Yup.
20,000 in cash.
Holy Shit,
that's a lot of money.
But he's like,
how much are going to save over the next 30 years?
It's worth it.
You know?
That's hilarious.
I always think to me it's like it's when you talk about,
you know,
the embedding both sides of the fence essentially.
How is that different though from,
a lot of us probably know some pretty darn serious gamblers and a lot of them
set their sports bets up that way where we are listened to.
If this happens,
I win and if that happens I win too.
And either way I'm covered.
And that's definitely how the house handles things.
So that essentially when we talk about the financial insiders in the economic
realm and that's the house,
so the house usually wins.
Yeah.
And it's not a fair game.
I mean,
I always say I love casinos,
I love going to Vegas,
I love doing fights there.
But if you're smart,
you look around,
you realize,
how do you think they built this giant buckets,
right?
That's right.
They didn't built it on you cracking blackjack and every week you know,
they,
they built it on people losing money here,
man.
That's what they don't offer you those free trips and the free hotel rooms to
come gamble because they're losing money on that.
There's so slick that if you win a ton of money,
they'll give you free tickets if you,
if you bet a ton of money.
And when a ton of money,
I'll fly you back.
They're like,
it's just a matter of time,
bitch.
We got you here.
Just a matter of time.
It's like having a fight with Cain Velasquez or if you don't knock him out,
you're going to run out of gas where he does.
There's no doubt.
It's just a matter of time he's going to get cha.
If there was 25 round fights,
Cain Velasquez would never fucking Lhuillier.
It's impossible for him to lose.
He just doesn't have,
his gas tank is like three times larger than a normal human beings.
That's the fucking house.
The House can't lose bench.
They got billions,
but they do like my friend Dana White is a,
uh,
he's a crazy degenerative gambling and uh,
he
gambles millions.
He's lost a million in the 90s.
Made as much as 6 million and night.
It's like you said on the podcast.
Yeah,
he's crazy.
He's crazy.
But he's a very wealthy man.
He was at,
uh,
the palms and he whacked him hard and they cut his credit line in half.
And he was like,
what?
Like,
what do we do?
We do shows there.
We do.
We put on UFC fight nights there and he know he's Catholic.
A lot of fucking money.
He's getting crazy,
but he won.
He won a lot and so they,
they cut his,
his,
his ability to gamble in half.
So he left the palms.
So he pulled the UFC fights out and said,
no.
Okay,
we'll go,
we'll go to the hard rock now.
What are you guys' retarded?
Like why would you do that?
Like you're going to get me eventually.
Don't you know you're going to get me you chicken shits.
And it's like they pulled his fucking credit to my exact opposite of what you're
supposed to do.
You are in the casinos,
you want the back,
you don't want them to send them away.
You get numbers crunchers who don't understand human nature and they,
they just look at it as like a management tool.
Well,
to get back to our risk management division,
I think there's a little bit of them going,
I don't know how he's gaming the system,
but I can judge from the results.
He's up to something.
Cut this guy,
he's counting cards.
He's this or that.
Just get them out.
I don't think you can count cards.
I mean,
I guess he can,
but in Blackjack,
but my point is they don't know what the next scam is and,
and,
and they can sometimes deduce that something's going on when those odds and
averages that they've worked out to the nth degree don't seem to be working with
you.
Right.
Well,
if you're,
if you're a smart player,
that definitely has an impact on blackjack.
Like blackjack is absolutely a skill game.
Right?
And I know they use a gang,
a decks now they don't just use one deck.
So I bet you can most certainly count those cards.
But I think you have to be like a super genius.
Yeah.
You have to be somebody like way smarter than Dana.
He ain't calling cards.
It's just getting lucky.
He just knows how to play.
You know,
he'll tell you he's not a fucking math genius.
He's a,
he's a business genius.
He knows that a pro fights.
Maybe that's because he inks Cain Velasquez suite team and puts him right next
door,
the other door.
And he's like,
he won,
right?
Yeah.
No problem.
100% in favor of gambling.
I'm 100% in favor of liquor too.
I'm 100% in favor of all options on the table.
It doesn't mean you're going to indulge in all of them or nor does it mean that
you should.
And a lot of the indulgences that are available right now are very unhealthy.
Like we talked about the gambling one.
I could go to Vegas,
you could go to vague.
We all could any weekend and gamble everything we own.
I know a dude who,
uh,
worked with a guy,
he worked with this guy for 10 years,
for 10 years.
This guy saved up all his money to go to Vegas.
And his idea was he's going to go to Vegas and gamble and you know,
and when he felt like that was his destiny,
so you saved up,
you know,
x amount of thousands of dollars for 10 years.
Lost it in the first 24 hours in Vegas,
came back home to Oklahoma and was just freaked out.
Just literally like shell shocked.
Like he had been attacked and raped by a hundred ghosts.
You know,
just like had this look on his face.
He would never recover from this port prick.
That's natural selection.
He's going to go follow a preacher in Munster now.
I mean,
I firmly believe that you should know that that's possible.
I think we all should know
big sign,
a big sign on the door.
You can lose ever walk in these doors and you can lose everything.
Welcome.
Yeah.
But I think that exists for everything.
I mean,
I think ultimately we have to learn from all these horrible examples that we see
on TV and in the news,
but every time some guy,
you know,
gets in a street fight and beat some guy to death and they're pulling them away
and we should all learn from that.
You know,
we should all learn from that and go,
hey,
you know what?
The human body is a lot more fragile than we like to pretend it is.
Who's that boxer that just fell into a coma?
Did you hear about that?
Fighting on Hbo the other night?
Yeah.
He uh,
they put him in a coma and brain swelling.
Yeah.
He had some swelling and then when they put him in a coma,
he had a stroke.
His name is,
uh,
it's really sad.
I just heard him interviewed.
Yeah.
Mega Med.
Dual,
a small,
uh,
to Abdu Salad all fighting.
I just,
I heard a pregame Eric Perez,
Mike pressed,
excuse me,
and Mike presents this up.
Pat asked Cuban boxer,
it was a great fight and that guy is,
I mean,
this is a perfect example of a guy being too tough for his own good.
Macramed took a tremendous amount of punishment in that fight,
but kept trying.
He just kept trying.
He didn't make it through the bout.
He made it through the bout,
I think.
Um,
it was a decision,
I believe it was a 10 round decision.
Yeah.
And he took a,
just a,
a furious amount of damage in that fight.
And afterwards they found out that he had broke his hand and broke his nose and
it was taken to the hospital where a small blood clot was discovered on his
brain.
And,
uh,
so they,
they induced him in a medically induced coma and then while he was in the coma,
he had a stroke.
So it's,
uh,
it's,
it's pretty bad.
That's what's made boxing hard for me.
I mean I'm,
I've always been a huge boxing fan and it's just,
it's football.
It's getting a little like this where you start to,
you start to wince,
you know,
you can't,
I never,
it's funny,
I know this is stupid to say,
but I would watch boxing and I never,
I never connected it with pain.
You know,
you're watching tactics and you're watching different strategies working with
you and you're watching foot movement and head movement.
And it never even occurred to me that you're watching,
you know,
the pain and the suffering and then someone dies and you go,
okay,
how much enjoyment did I get out of this sport?
And I still watch it.
But this is the kind of thing that just reminds you of,
of what's going on in there.
Well for me it has an even deeper connection because I've competed,
cause I've fought a few kickboxing bouts and probably,
I don't know how many taekwondo bouts,
but it was over a period of like six,
six or seven years.
It was all I did with my life and was mine a hundred percent waking life.
So I competed a lot in full contact tournament's and I got away with it.
I got lucky,
but I've seen some guys get really hurt.
I see.
I've seen some guys get kicked the head where
they were just really never the same person again.
Doesn't this go to what you were saying though about you know,
you kind of have a right,
it's like,
yeah,
talk to these boxers who are,
like you said,
every day they're training,
you're going to tell this person they can't do that as long as they know the
risks.
To this day.
That was one of the most important things I ever did as far as developing me as
a human being because it was terrifying.
It was terrifying and I got really good at it and I got really good at
competing.
In a really dangerous high high risk quick happening situation like striking,
especially like the weight class that was false kickboxing at one 60 and these
light guys,
everyone moves really fast,
they all hit hard is a scary weight class,
lot of knockouts and you're,
when you're competing in that sort of an environment,
your training and that sort of environment on a regular basis,
regular shit just doesn't scare you the same way regular people and they flare
up and yell or someone gets do she with you.
It doesn't have this overwhelming sense of fear that it has on a lot of people
and I've seen people in confrontations where a guy and another guy were in a
confrontation and something happens mostly because one guy like loses his
ability to stay calm.
Like he's so confused and nervous that he can't react properly.
When I see that,
I see that's a human with a deficit in the development of their character.
I don't think he,
unless you have been there,
I don't think that physical violence is something that you're just born and
knowing how to deal with,
you know,
he's like,
either you are used to it cause you got beat up at dawn as a kid or you're used
to it cause you fought a lot or you're used to it because of something,
but you're not gonna,
you know the first time is that pence,
he's fucking scary.
That's why the scariest kids to fight her kids who've got beat by their dad.
Yeah,
exactly.
Those kids though,
I remember competing against kids that I knew had like really violent
relationships with their fathers.
Those kids were like really used to getting hit.
Yup.
This is a different thing.
Like,
and they,
they,
it was a part of normal everyday life getting smacked around.
Well,
I looked up,
you know,
though,
and this gets me back to not thinking about the pain in boxing.
I remember,
um,
there was a Ryan O'Neal,
I think it was,
he was doing the,
the remake of the champ movie and,
and they had on on site one of these,
uh,
one of these actual boxers who was going to kind of,
you know,
teach him a little bit about how to do this or that.
And he says,
he tells the story,
he says,
at one point,
he goes,
the boxer who was,
who was working with him said,
I want you to hit me.
And he said,
okay,
I'm not going to hit you.
And you know,
long time hit me,
you got to hit me.
So,
so we finally hits him.
He goes,
no,
I mean,
really hit me,
you know,
and he says,
I squared up and I hit him as hard as I could.
He goes,
no,
I mean,
really hit me.
And,
and you start to realize that guys who take lots of punches all the time in
training and everything that,
that there you,
it doesn't do to them what it would do to you.
And,
well,
not you,
me,
but,
but to them the punches can do just as much damage to their brain,
but in terms of shaking them or hurting them,
it's not the thing when you're used to
it.
Well,
the one,
one of the big things is the shock of being hit.
The shock of being hit is how a lot of people,
they literally go into a freeze mode and they can't move correctly and they get
knocked out.
Like their body shuts off and it's,
it's being overwhelmed by the moment,
by the,
the fact that you're actually engaged in arm and I mean hand to hand combat with
somebody.
That's a weird feeling.
I've seen it happen.
I've seen guys fall apart like in street fights and stuff.
I've seen,
I've seen street fights that happened just because the guy was scared.
You know that,
that that's a possibility too.
That gets done.
The more scared you are,
the more you called for it because then you're encouraging the other because he
found out scared.
It's like damn makes the other person and sink twice.
He's like,
I really want to get into with this.
Crazy motherfucker was not scared of getting hurt.
It also doesn't progress the correct way.
You know,
the,
the way that it like the natural way in a,
in a idiots mind is I yell at you,
you either back down and get scared and I kick your ass or you yell back at me
and we fucking puffed chests until somebody fucks up and makes the wrong move.
But if the guy backs down,
you know that you can press forward instinct,
the natural instinct of the bullies to press forward.
Yup.
It's almost unavoidable.
I think that's,
people do themselves a huge disservice by not understanding at least some form
of martial arts,
at least having some experience in it.
You know,
hopefully sell that.
We won't need it though.
That book that we are
talking about right before we come on with [inaudible] phone,
the um,
the Persian expedition,
one of his speeches when they already is 10,000 Greek guys like way behind enemy
lines in Persian territory.
They have to make their way back home.
It looks desperate.
They have no chance.
And one of he needs sort of in these like speech that he's trying to give them
to rally them up.
Uh,
one of the things he says is exactly what you are saying about the psychologies.
If you guys are scared now,
Yara,
we'll going to die.
They're just no way.
Because if you are afraid of dying,
that's exactly what's going to happen.
If you guys are willing to die because you just,
you know that your odds are desperate but you're willing to just go for it
because a,
you don't have any other chance be,
you'll go for it with honor.
The odds are not all you are going to behave honorably by your actually your
chances of surviving improved dramatic critically.
That makes sense though.
The universe favors bravery doesn't want weak bitches out there spreading their
seeds.
Sorry.
That's a fact.
It's a fact.
You know,
there's a weird trend today to like almost like encourage weakness.
I think encouraging kindness is always very important,
but it gets really confused with encouraging weakness.
There's,
there's a lot of like bitch ass men out there that it would help them.
It would benefit them.
Take a fucking boot clamp class,
you know,
just to do something with your body other than sitting.
That's shit
drive me insane because you know,
the fact that we have moved beyond the stupid stereotype of the tough macho man
and the woman who stay back,
that's nice.
But at the same time solve then Eskom and the price of people giving up the good
sides of the stereotype.
You know,
if the stereotype of the man was you are strong and tough,
but you're also,
you know,
emotionally deficient and not very sensitive radar.
And I'm working on the kindness aspect.
As you've noted.
The idea has been,
well then strength is bad.
Who should get rid of that?
Yeah,
that's,
that's really good.
It's
so stupid.
It's not fun.
People associate prejudice.
Lee,
anything male,
masculine,
anything unapologetically masculine with suppression of the feminine,
with suppression,
like with antifeminist ideas like I have on more than one occasion gotten into
it with uh,
people that call themselves feminists.
And their idea was that something that I had said like doesn't promote
femininity or does it or is an anti feminine.
This is the furthest couldn't be true.
I just expect a balance.
Yeah.
Expect cycle to just be people.
Exactly.
You know,
I don't,
when you start looking at feminist or masculinist or you know,
like I don't,
I don't,
that doesn't mean shit to me.
What means shit to me is leave me alone.
I'll leave you alone.
I'll give you the right to do anything you want to do.
But you can't say I'm an ape cause I like working out.
Okay.
You can't say I'm an asshole because I've got some fucking guns.
All right.
That's nonsense.
If you're a man and you,
you don't work out because it's not enjoyable for you.
I totally understand.
But the idea that someone who does or someone who does participate in manly type
shit is an asshole because of that.
You're like,
I,
I watched this one thing,
it was just horrible piece that someone wrote about the,
uh,
the rape in Ohio with those,
those high school kids,
one of the most disgusting aspects of male culture.
Yup.
This ability to get someone fucked up and do that to them and treat them as a
sub human.
I mean it is without a doubt one of the scariest,
darkest aspects of the,
of men that they can do that.
But in this article they were talking about how,
let's just face the facts,
all high school athletes are assholes.
Yeah.
That's the logical conclusion.
The flow from that.
It's like what it hurt my head was I was a blog,
it was a blog and somebody wrote,
but it was just,
I was like,
oh come.
I mean it was a very progressive,
very left wing blog that I visit sometimes.
And the,
you know,
they were actually saying that supporting the ideas of competition actually
encourages people to treat people as subhuman.
And that's an old,
old,
uh,
idea.
When you think about that.
Um,
listen,
I think we,
we exist in a,
in a realm where it's going to be competitive no matter what you do.
So I think to pretend we're going to deemphasize these things doesn't do anybody
any,
any good down the road.
Cause then once you drop them in life,
they're not prepared.
Well I,
it is a little bit like what you were saying about the,
about the fighting but,
but like with my kids,
you don't,
you don't want to over,
you don't want to crush anybody early on.
You want to nurture them so that they can handle the competition.
But if you don't teach them about competition there,
you're not preparing them for life.
And that's when you're going to release them into a world where,
I mean if those people really don't want to competitive world,
think about how much you would have to do to turn off the competitive world.
How much intrusion that would have to be on all of our lives.
There goes your stock market right away,
right?
I mean the economy isn't that a little like what some of the really hardcore
communist ideas we're about where we are.
Different people have different capabilities.
So forcing them to compete as inherently unequal because you and I are born
different,
so we'll compensate for that and blend it out.
Sounds great in theory.
But the amount of work it takes to recreate a whole system,
you know where you don't have competition,
you don't have differences is
worse than the disease.
Yeah.
Even quizzy are treating people like they are sick as opposed to treating
somebody like you are going to teach everyone.
Man,
woman doesn't matter.
Gender doesn't come into place.
Everybody should be strong.
Everybody should be kind.
Everybody should have both of the qualities that are normally attributed to only
one gender or the other.
They are human qualities.
There are good qualities there.
What you need to be a complete human being,
you in core edge,
that stuff and you make it a must complete human being,
the creme possibility,
and they will deal with whatever shape life throws at them,
competitive or otherwise,
because they're always going to be challenges and as he safe,
there are no,
but a partition for the challenges they are are going to come your way,
whether you like it or not.
No matter how safe you make the word,
then you're dead meat already.
You know?
Then you're going to get squashed the first time that universe goes booyah too.
You're going to fit a coyote and crash.
For me,
the big question in a competitively based system is not the competition part and
not the winning part.
It's what do you do with the people who
come out on the short end of the stick?
Because I think in a sink or swim system,
you're going to find that the people who are sinking are going to decide that
the system socks and we're going to change it because there's too many losers.
I've always said that one of the things that you do when you know,
I said in recent show that you know poverty is going to come back to bite us all
in the ass one day if we don't do something about it.
Not because you should care about poor people,
but because eventually if they're hurting enough,
they will make you care about them.
They will,
they will turn the system around.
I mean you can outcompete them all you want,
but they'll come and burn down your nice house at a certain point.
So,
so to me,
when you talk about a competitive system,
the winters aren't the issue.
It's what you do with the people cause you're going to have some losers in a
competitive system.
How do you mitigate the downsides of that?
And that's what I always try.
It's trying to
think about,
that's a very good point.
That's a very,
very good point.
You're,
you're always going to have good and bad in the,
you're always going to have conflict.
You're always going to in in the,
the ability to recognize that and deal with whatever comes in front of you is
very important.
Well,
like you said,
you're going to have kids who get raised by parents who beat the hell out of
them and who don't raise them the right way and who don't give him those
qualities,
Daniella,
that you were talking about,
and then you're going to unleash those people in the world and say,
go compete with this guy who went to Harvard and had a great education and it
was born with a lot of money.
The world's had unequal place.
You can't fix that,
but you can build that into your thinking.
I think it's also,
there's such a
broad spectrum of human beings and what the human being,
where they fit into society.
Where there places,
like I have a lot of friends that have like zero willpower but they make amazing
standup Comedians,
you know,
and that's where they might go together.
They're very well mine.
Like Joey Diaz is my favorite example and Joey has willpower.
He gets up in the morning,
everything I price,
you know,
300 and whatever pounds.
He doesn't give a fuck.
And he's,
he's an animal,
he's just savage.
But he's also the funniest human being I've ever met in my life.
It's like you can't,
you can't make a Joey Diaz if you get some guy who's doing fucking sit ups every
morning,
a thousand sit ups and Chin ups and jogging around the block and only eating
Kale,
it's not going to be that guy.
You need a guy went to jail,
did a lot of coke,
you know,
kidnapped the guy.
You need all that,
you know,
like in order to get a guy who's that wild and crazy and funny.
And I feel like the real problem that we have in raising children is all they
teach in school is to try to filter you into standard position in,
in,
in the,
in the economy standard job.
Whether it's the filter you towards a career and one,
one or more very definable things,
right?
There's a lot of people out there with talents that never get nurtured.
They just can't figure out their way in that system because it's
taught them so small.
Such a small chunk of the spectrum is taught well.
It goes cool,
are designed to make you average.
That's what schools are about,
which if you are a considerably below average because of your opportunities in
life,
great.
That's a step up.
But if you are not and that goes for the other 50% of humanity,
Dan is just designed to make it not nurture your talents,
not do all the sinks and try to make you fit in the little box and [inaudible]
of the realities and that now because the people who create schools are evil and
they just want to faculty or life,
he's because they need to go with Samsung.
That knowledge as something that can be objectively tested.
What is that?
You can objectively test.
Can you test some body's wisdom?
I was married,
Arl,
cool of human being.
They are objectively not really.
What you can do is you can test a well,
they speak back in formation at you,
which is a skill in itself that it's better than not knowing.
Now you need to have the discipline.
You need to know some things.
It's cool.
It makes you,
it gives you those average qualities,
but it says nothing about what you're going to do with them.
Whether you're going to be brilliant,
whether you're going to be able to use these ideas in an amazing way.
And the realities that gets to most people in charge of schools feel that's too
subjective.
When start talking about wisdom.
Ah,
what the fuck is waste on me is your wisdom is not my definition.
So we can really test it where we can test these.
And so you'll go back to the,
they don't want to get sued by the people who don't do well.
Like if I come into class and I say I'll give you an a cause,
you're really fucking smart and I can see it now you are really are not that
good.
So sorry.
You got to see the person who got to see is going to be a fuck you.
You know why?
Why are you giving me,
Oh,
show me why you know where he is in the exactly that I deserve this.
And part of the game is the stuff that you can prove in that fashion is not the
kind of knowledge to make a complete human being is the kind of annoy
application of that knowledge.
In a capitalist society is what we tried to find as proof that you've actually
got some intelligence buys x,
y people who,
you know,
you might not even think that that smart,
but if they're very successful financially and go,
well,
he's smart at that.
Right?
You know,
it's,
there's that thing [inaudible] I think what you're trying to do theoretically in
an education system is to prepare people to succeed in life.
And the problem that I think the education system has is that it's stuck in a
design for an era where succeeding in life is very different than succeeding in
life today.
You're not going to go onto the factory assembly line.
You're not going to do those kinds of things.
But the way our system has evolved is to create people who can succeed at that.
The problem is,
is that what we have now is a creativity based economy that we're moving towards
and teaching creativity.
One would be,
it's tremendously hard and we haven't worked to create that on a mass system
where you've got schools that are,
I mean obviously schools work with creativity,
but it's a different thing entirely to sit there and go,
we're going to start in the first grade and by the time you graduate high
school,
we are going to maximize your creative abilities that are unique to you.
You know,
Danielle,
you were saying this,
part of the problem is you could talk about creativity,
but Joe's creative gifts are going to be different than yours and mine and you
can't have a standard course.
Right?
Well,
I haven't thought of one anyway that can take your gifts and your gifts and
bring them to maturity.
Unless we all share those gifts because you know your,
your gifts are in one area,
you're gives her an another.
The problem is,
is that in our system,
there are no assembly lines or or few,
you can't educate the mass of people to take a bunch of jobs that don't exist
anymore.
So I think the system has to redesign itself to push creativity.
And there's also some
utopian ideals and raising kids that are contrary to human nature,
like this new thing that they're doing where or not having kids when,
when you know,
when they're playing like ball games and no one wins,
you know,
when they're little.
This is back to your competition.
Yeah.
Seriously.
Out of beads,
peas as a kid.
Did you ever heard of this before?
It's a joke.
I mean it's,
I mean it's pretty widespread.
Been going on for quite awhile.
It trophies for everyone,
that kind of thing.
Yeah.
Um,
I dunno how I would Google that,
but uh,
they're not giving out first and second place anymore then not then you know.
Well it's not a broad brush.
I was going to say,
yeah,
some places,
no,
you don't keep score.
A lot of kids at the younger,
they don't do that anymore.
We kept scoring tee ball when I was a kid and you rubbed someone's nose in it.
If they lost,
there was no coach pitch.
I had five year old boys.
You couldn't do anything but hit me with the ball pitching to me all day.
There are no schools,
there are no losers.
You're just the last winner.
I'm sorry I have to go throw up.
I'll be right back.
I mean,
I think that competition,
we all hate losing and therefore we connect competition with being a negative
thing.
I don't think,
I don't think it's a negative thing at all.
I think competition is important.
I think it's important in art.
I think it's important in everything you know?
And you might say,
oh well that's not the,
the,
you know,
the real spirit of art.
It's not competition.
You're right,
it's not.
But that competition can motivate the accomplishment of work and the
accomplishment of work.
Sometimes,
you know,
procrastination or what have you can,
you can delay someone releasing their art.
So in that way,
the competition inspires the creation of art.
It's not always,
and most of the time you're better off with that competition being internal or
not,
not even being a competition,
but rather an embracement of the complexities of figuring out whatever thing
you're working on.
But that's still you.
There's,
there's something going on.
There's a game going on,
whether it's going on with you and your head,
whether it's going on with the audience,
it's going to review whatever you're creating,
like a podcast or whether it's going on with you,
any competing directly against your peers and it,
and they're sensing to me,
I love something about competition cause I love the media feedback it gives you,
yeah know he's like you go out there,
you do what you can to do and at the end of the day you see the results.
We don't pull it off or you didn't losing.
To me,
as horrible as that feel,
as it fucking sucks and you feel like,
you know,
you're so mad,
he's the best team that can happen to you because that's,
you know,
we need,
you are going to keep doing the same thing you've always done.
You have no motivation to push harder because look,
I'm already doing great.
Motivation may be fear of losing.
Yeah,
exactly.
And then when you do lose,
Danny forces you to go back to the drawing board and figure out,
okay,
how can I,
I ran into the stumbling block.
How can I go around it?
And in fact these,
you know these bullshit about,
you know,
no losers.
No,
we never know.
Not letting somebody experience what it is to do your best and still lose.
You're not doing them any favor because the fact is in life immediately on times
just because that's the design of life shit is going to happen whether you like
it or not,
whether it's fair or not,
whether you deserve it or not.
And how you respond to that.
If you feel that,
why did this happen to me?
You know,
it's unfair.
It's I shouldn't be in this place.
I shouldn't feel like shit.
Well you do now what you know.
And that's that experience of losing in that case is you're losing at the game
of life,
not necessar to because of your fault.
Maybe it is,
maybe it isn't.
Now are you out of fuckery?
Gonna respond to this.
If you have been there a million times,
maybe you have develop the muscle to grow out of it.
If you have never been there the first time,
that light slap you around,
you freak out.
And isn't
that sort of one of the reasons why our economy and society itself is so fucked
up?
It's because we're so god damn competitive and it's because it's so natural to
do that.
When you start controlling some of the money,
you want to control more of the money.
You know you,
you,
when you start making some of the laws,
Ben,
to help and benefit your business.
Right?
Dude,
I watched a really disturbing documentary this past couple of days.
It was gas land.
Have you seen that or heard of it?
I haven't seen Holy Shit.
You want to talk about a must see hydraulic fracturing,
what they call fracking?
Yeah.
Wow.
It's interesting why it's scary shit,
what they're doing and this guy breaks it down.
The amount of wells that they have.
I had no idea.
It's a lot.
And how many people's drinking water is for forever poisoned.
I mean,
you're talking about giant chunks of America that are rendered poisonous.
Well,
understand something.
This is the wonderful example now of if somebody came to you and said,
how much money would we have to give you to poison your country?
What does that worth?
Because look at the other side of this.
Fracking as it's called,
has taken the United States from an energy really insufficient position where we
were in the Middle East.
We're in all these places because of the energy question and I mean in in a
geologic sense,
overnight turned us into an energy exporter again and we haven't been that way
since.
I mean we've always explored it energy,
but I mean the 1960s were like the last really high water mark where we had lots
of oil and we didn't have to worry.
All of a sudden we're the natural gas kings and everything again and there's a
ton of money.
That amount of money,
the amount we're talking about here,
not just money for now,
money for 10 years from now,
20 this is like longterm,
lots of money you that money will buy anything.
Well,
by poisoning your water supply will by earthquakes that destroyed small Oklahoma
towns.
It.
Well,
it's an interesting thing to see what we're willing to sell for a ton of money
that doesn't go to Joe Rogan or Dan Carlin by the west coast for the problem is
the word we.
It's not what we're willing.
Most people had no idea this was even happening until it was already too late
and during the Bush administration,
this,
this documentary Gasland highlights how this all came to be and how Dick Cheney
signed over these new exemptions that are,
you didn't have to follow the water out of the clean water act,
the clean air act,
all those were exempt.
Fracturing was exempt,
so you could just fuck everything up in order to get to,
it's essentially like a small ocean of natural gas.
The amount that's under New York and a big,
big chunks of the country in Texas.
It's huge.
It's gigantic change the entire energy situation on the planet,
but these people have water that comes out of their faucet that you can light on
fire.
Yep.
Surprise lighted on fire.
There's more than 500 different chemicals that they have to pump into the ground
in order to break up this natural gas and then extract it.
And when they do that,
they basically,
everything gets mixed up together.
The well water gets mixed up with the chemicals,
gets Mitch mixed up with the natural gas and it's just talk sick as fuck.
It's coming out of holes in the ground and you can come up to it and light it on
fire.
It's mad.
No,
you know what the best chance,
and it's a sad thing.
The best chance you have of combating that amount of money over something is
when we have screwed up so much of the fresh water supply that the fresh water
actually becomes worth more.
And you're already seeing this happening in some places where,
where they're talking about,
you know,
do we sell water rights to California from the Colorado River or this or that.
The other and the amounts of money that they're talking about.
I mean,
they're already talking about,
you know,
why should water be considered a feature that's owned by everybody?
Can I buy the water in the Colorado River and then can I sell it back to you?
So I mean,
the old joke is that if you buy the bottled water,
it's worth more than gasoline.
You know,
at that amount.
If you go to the store,
well what happens when it really is worth more than gasoline in large
quantities?
Then all of a sudden fracking sounds like you're destroying and even more
important,
I can get more money for that water,
then I can get for that natural gas.
That's the only chance we have in a system driven by money,
I think to to keep the waterfront.
It's incredibly short.
Yeah.
Decided and the amount of deception that's gone on to cover the amount of damage
that's been done is staggering.
I mean,
when these people tell their stories,
it's,
it's incredibly hard to watch and listen to cause people get sick because they
were drinking the water that kids get sick.
The water,
like for the longest time,
they wouldn't meant that there was anything wrong with the water.
And then they started giving people water.
They give it.
They set up these giant tanks and pumping water to them every week so that they
get their water from that instead of their wells they've had for you know,
a hundred plus years.
It's crazy shit man.
It's crazy shit to watch.
But this is where you see the corruption of our political system,
which is what's destroying you would think that people who live in places where
they can light their water on fire would have their representatives in
Washington working to stop that.
But that's where your free speech rights and my free speech rights are not equal
to the free speech rights of these other people.
And this is where I always argue with the courts that say that money is free
speech,
which I don't mind except who said you get 50 or 100 times my free speech
rights.
The,
the Internet I think ultimately is going to be a place where people vote on
things and it's also ultimately going to be a place where people can donate to
campaigns that promote values they believe in.
And I think that is going to be a special interest along with all the other
special interests in the world competing for influence.
But what about that really changed things?
They'd make it illegal?
Well I think it's about money and I think ultimately if,
if people invest money in
a party and a lobbyist and an idea that supports the things that they believe
in,
that money can influence people just as easily as the money that supports
fracking or the money support.
The idea is that it's just trading of commodities.
So let's buy a legislator,
should we get the group together?
I'm taking up a cause.
We're going to by Senator Ron Wyden sending around.
My is probably already on,
but you know this guy who's been working for the fracking industry,
how much do you need dude?
You know,
you get him out of the tape of the,
how much is it going to take to bring you over to our side?
I have powerful backers.
The guy was cut off in Vegas.
He can't gamble anymore.
He's got a lot of money and you know what?
What's it going to take to buy this particular,
I mean maybe we should just do that.
The part maybe that's unfair about this is that you're never offered the chance
to buy a legislator that's kept to a small group of people in a smoke filled
back room.
Maybe what we need is,
look,
if you're going to be sold,
give us the option of buying to,
we collectively have a fuck load of money to buy me a legend to write off,
isn't it?
Could you buy a legislated and that our business expense?
Yes it is.
If it helps my business,
can't call it buying off though.
We have to call it something creative risk management.
That's right.
You know that.
You've got that podcast,
a troll lawsuit.
I'm going to buy a few legislators and get them in my corner and then I'm going
to write that off on us.
Taxpayers can pick up my buying of the cause.
That's how it's done at the best levels.
Right.
Did ultimately,
that would be a smart thing for them to pursue just by virtue of the fact that
there's more money there than there is in all the corporations combined.
I know it's a lot harder to please all of us that just that one guy,
you're right,
but the potential for extracting money off of a giant group by 300 million,
even if you get 1% that's still a huge amount of human beings that are donating
money.
Well,
the audience is going to say that already exists.
I mean,
look at all the small contribution,
but it's not the same as walking up to somebody and saying,
listen,
I went to all my friends and here's $5 million.
Right?
Yeah.
Because the guy,
you know,
the corporation was gonna.
They are going to invest the money to buy off a vote to get what they want.
They are going to make that amount of money 50 times over in the next tier.
Right.
The person who's going to donate to a campaign,
they are doing that in order to avoid something to be taken from them.
Whether it's Google out there or something,
they're not going to see their money back.
They are not going to,
I'm going to make more money on it.
So there is a little bit of hesitancy and other people are like,
fuck,
really?
Do I have to pay for something that I still had until yesterday?
And Oh man,
you know,
there's not that pay off of like you're going to win big.
Is Your plane a defensive game where it's like you're just so risk avoidance.
Yeah.
It's sort of like you have that money and you have to invest it in making sure
they don't rob you in the future.
Yeah,
exactly.
Rather than invest in you too,
rob,
everybody else,
one of the others either get your agenda across,
but the idea that these business come,
these,
these companies that have in enforced fracking or encourage fracking or spent
money to make it happen.
And this guy goes really clearly into detail about how it all took place and
you,
they're ruining like a huge chunk of the country and they're doing it right in
front of everybody's face and no one can stop it.
And the worst part is they won't be around when the bill comes due for kicking
it up either.
You can't clean it up.
That's what's really crazy.
These,
uh,
these people,
one of the people that got incredibly sick,
this woman got sick because they,
it turned out that these filters that they had set up don't work with the
chemicals that they use for fracking.
The chemicals actually eat the membranes of the
filter.
So she,
it was all,
uh,
some of the chemicals were getting through to her and she was getting incredibly
sick,
neurological damage,
all sorts of like really,
like everyone's sick,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's an incredible documentary.
I,
I've,
it's very hard to protect the water supply.
You remember here in California with that gasoline additive that sunk into the
ground and made it into the water and it,
and it was a weird situation because of the additive had been put in there to
take some of the lead from the air pollution and then it was seeping into the
ground water.
So you're damned if you do,
damned if you don't.
But that's the problem is it doesn't take a whole lot to seep into the water
supply and then you're screwed.
What was that that you just put up that said Gaslamp producers put it up.
We'll put it up.
What does it say that I don't know how they could mislead debunking things about
both documentaries on gas land is one and two and they're both saying there's
some,
well,
but just put up the thing that I asked the Gaslamp producer misled viewers on.
What does it show?
Rogan is space spreading false information.
We could see it.
It said that it's been happening since the 1930s.
Um,
this isn't necessarily just from,
their water was flammable before fracking.
You know,
it's funny Phil,
he's,
every time you expose anything you're going to have the next day.
15 sites saying no,
you made the top is not reality.
It's not that a public relations firms or four.
Exactly right.
Yup.
Yup,
Yeah.
I think that it's hard to know who the fuck is right in that situation.
But somewhere in the country you can fucking without a doubt guarantee that
these people have been poisoned.
Whether the lighting,
the water on fire,
it,
it always existed.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
Poisoning the citizens is an age old thing.
I mean we do it it nuclear plants,
we do it.
I mean there's been lots of situations where you're living near something that
might be bad for you and,
and that's nothing new.
That's what's crazy is that,
is that,
that's always taken a back seat to somebody profits somewhere.
And that's,
that's a bit sad that we can't as an entire population being poisoned balance
out the interests of those people who decide poisoning is,
is okay.
Cause they can go to Hawaii because I mean from their point of view,
you know,
a corporation,
you're in the business of making money.
We are not in the business of being nice.
We are not going to be off me mean he's whatever it takes to make money,
you'll do it.
If he takes screwing people over.
Oh well even if you didn't want to make money,
you may have a fiduciary responsibility to your shareholders to maximize that.
Wouldn't that be funny?
I don't really want to frack.
Right.
But uh,
but you know,
the shareholders will take me out if I don't,
but that's the problem.
He said,
I'll go to jail.
That's the corporation on,
right.
The role of government in a beauty for labs toward would be today actually in
force.
Lowe's to stop the stuff that's damaging to the public.
That's only good for those.
What job?
You're out the loop.
You brought up a loophole.
And to me that's the biggest thing that I think people don't understand is that
you can make all the laws in the world if you let the loopholes happen.
They don't mean,
it's like people say to me,
Dan,
why do you keep saying the fourth amendment's going the way the fourth
amendment's their courts ruling.
Yeah,
but you Swiss cheese that enough.
It doesn't matter anymore.
Right.
This stuff is meaningless unless it's accessible
barrier.
I got to watch research this now because a bunch of people in my message board
or putting up all these,
uh,
websites that say that they're debunking gas land,
first of all,
a,
I would without a doubt,
I would imagine that if I was working for the fracking industry and someone put
out a hit piece on fracking,
that I would debunk the fucking shit out of him.
Yeah.
Even if it doesn't make any sense that d bunkie doesn't make any sense.
And if you're a legislator who voted to allow it,
you'd have the same interest.
Yeah.
But that said,
I haven't read any of the debunking,
so I'll read that and I'll get back.
Yeah.
But even if you don't focus on the specific example,
you look at the general picture is fucking undeniable that were poisoned in our
environment that I don't think you can debunk that.
It's like,
no,
it's,
that's just facts.
So you'll pick one specific example.
They may not be exactly 100% through who the fuck cares.
The general picture remained the same.
That's not going to change.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I dunno man.
I think that we do really for without a doubt,
have an issue with the fact that people were super competitive and that people
are progressive in nature.
I mean,
but I mean by progressive they move forward.
If they have $2,
they want three.
If they have three,
they want four.
It's a natural,
weird thing that we do.
I was like,
I was trying to explain anal sex to somebody and I was in a girl is a natural
segue.
Why did guys,
why you guys want to do that?
I go,
because they have regular sex with you and then they go,
can I put it in your mouth?
And they go,
yeah.
okay,
well what about that?
And that's just,
it's a natural,
weird progression.
I mean all that stuff happens when you hear about like crazy,
not a philosophy major jury.
When you hear about like crazy super freaks that have like gigantic orgies,
how did that happen?
Did they just start off having orgies?
No,
they started out with regular sex and they've got a lot of regular sex and they
started getting boards.
They brought an extra girls and before you know what they're having these freaky
sex parties,
it's a natural thing of progression.
People,
if they're,
if they can run five miles,
they want to run 10 if they got their brown belt,
they want to get their black.
So it's competition,
which you guys were talking about how great it was all the time and now you're
slamming it,
make up your law.
That's not what I'm saying.
I say
the idea's gone wild.
The idea of what makes a human exceptional,
what make makes a human create everything that exists really,
I think from electronics to the wheel to houses and everything.
There's this natural desire for humans to improve upon.
What they've already done.
And I think that extends to control.
I think it extends to evil as well.
It's one of my old my arguments when a,
when everyone would talk about like uh,
problems with government and whether or not there's still corruption in
government.
All you have to do is look back on the corruption that you can document for a
fact that happened in the 1960s and know that there's no bodies,
there's no like a slew of people lives ruined careers destroyed parties brought
down now is actually very little.
If you think about exactly what they're absolutely positively guilty doing.
This is very little damage and you know that that everything progresses.
So the amount of utter and complete total corruption that exists today and the
sophistication of it would naturally
be above and beyond what existed documentable from the 19 six
let me take it to a different level cause I think it's a different thing.
I think that we are incentivized as human beings going back to primate times to
look at things through a short term lens there.
The carrots and sticks are all set up for the short term approach.
You know,
you brought up wisdom awhile ago,
Daniella wisdom is being able to look at things from a longterm perspective.
Now it's a perfect example is investing.
Uh,
in the old days,
you know,
ty Cobb would buy coca cola shares and when he died he had all these cocacola
shares on his chest,
did the hospital that he'd had for forever,
you know,
hell yeah.
Oh yeah.
He was so afraid someone would take his,
his,
so he kept it.
So he's got,
he's two,
he's got all these shares.
He's owned forever because to him he wasn't going to sell them in five minutes.
He was in it for the long term.
Our society is set up for the short term.
Making money is set up for the short term.
There is no interest in saying something like,
well let's protect clean water.
Who are you protecting it for?
I won't be around to enjoy that clean water.
By the time that happens,
I'm dead now.
What can I make in the short term?
Politics is the same way.
It's like when people were talking about President Obama lying about the
healthcare planning,
but keeping your own doctor right and all that stuff.
He's incentivized to do that.
All he cared about was winning that next election.
You will worry about the fallout later.
None of this matters if you lose right dealing with the fallout of the lie
later,
there's no incentive to not lie.
The incentives are all on the,
and this is if you're an intelligent human being weighing the pros and cons,
you are not incentivized to think longterm and yet that may be the only solution
for the planet.
You talk about long term.
If we can't somehow contradict where the incentives are and go against our
natural primate instincts,
we might not be able to make it work.
I think it's going to take
a greater level of awareness culturally than exists today.
I think the great level of awareness,
the,
the really,
truly objective view of humanity and the potential possibilities of the future
is something that is contemplated by few groups,
small groups of people,
people sitting in conversation,
dinner parties and stuff.
But if you think of the greater whole of humanity,
the,
the amount of damage we're doing to the world on a daily basis,
the amount of like really ridiculous behavior that operates our financial and,
and,
and justice system and our political systems.
It's all like complete and total chaos.
And yet it still continues in the exact same way it always has before.
There's only small groups of people that speak out against it.
I think once the,
the,
the sphere of understanding of like what,
what a complete disaster this world is because of our actions and because of our
inability to correct those actions.
Once that understanding
is,
is in place,
then hopefully it's not too late.
There'll be some sort of way to turn back the tide.
But I feel like it's an ebb and a flow thing,
much like everything in life.
And I think it's almost like we have to fucking poison the ocean before we
realize it's ridiculous and then stop doing it.
I think it's going to be money.
I think.
I think somewhere down the road when water for clean water,
for example,
is worth a bazillion dollars to Halliburton and they buy the water,
then the rules will be,
you can't,
you can't piss in water anywhere because you know,
you might be,
then all of the money going to Washington will be to preserve water.
Will it preserve Halliburton's water supply?
Otherwise their profits will be impacted when they sell it back to the public.
I don't,
I,
you know,
Joe,
you always need,
you know,
you,
Oh,
you want human nature to improve and you think it's going to happen and I don't
disagree with you.
The problem is,
is that so many people like Dick Cheney have to be improved too before this
works that I don't see that happening.
I see it.
It's going the other way.
Their incentives have to become the,
there's still going to want money.
They're still going to think short term,
but the incentives have to change so that protecting the environment becomes the
the way to keep your millions in tact as opposed to,
you know,
polluting the environment becomes the way to keep your millions in tax.
But if you look at the dissolving of boundaries between people and information
and how that trend is going to continue,
I think that our idea of looking at the possibilities of the future based on how
humans were able to run the world just 10 years ago are kind of ridiculous when
you think about it from 100 years from now,
the options won't be available because the amount of transparency that will be
required to communicate with people is going to be completely different.
It's gonna be very hard to hold back reality.
You're assuming that there's not going to be some David Cameron cracked down,
you know,
between now and then.
I don't think they can do it.
And I think even if they did,
the young people that are coming up that are more in line with the ideas of an
anonymous or the ideas of open source internet,
the ideas of spreading information and what a massively important thing that is
for society and human culture as a whole,
I think they're overwhelming and I think they're,
they're going to continue that trend.
The people that know that,
the,
the idea of anybody being able to control information,
they are literally controlling.
If they do that,
they're controlling educational evolution.
They're controlling the ability for,
are you suggesting they wouldn't want to,
can't,
you can't do it.
I don't think you could do it.
Is that a challenge?
It's like triage.
It's like I pull
all the sand off the beaches.
Uh,
and let's see,
it happened.
I want to stop that you guys are saying,
I actually think it goes hand in hand because what you're saying Joe,
about the fact that a certain level of transformation in terms of consciousness,
in terms of priorities that happen at a mass level when enough people,
we'd sort of a critical mass that feeds into dance arguments that at that point
corporations are going to respond to it because there's money attached to it.
So I don't think he's just purely from an economic standpoint and he's clearly
not purely from a consciousness standpoint is going to go ahead.
I mean it's happening now,
right?
He's like more and more people care about environmental issues.
So companies that market themselves as were nice to the environment can hike
their prices a little bit because they know that they are going to have some
people who buy them.
They are products because of those values.
Yeah.
Could you imagine if you were buying some gas that costs 10 cents less per
gallon,
but it,
you know,
it was guarantee comes from like child labor in some shitty part of the country
in the world where the Dolphin Safe Tuna label thing.
Yeah,
exactly.
I think that it's going to be impossible in the future to hide any evil
behavior.
I think right now it's still too muddy.
It's still to money.
I think as technology advances and approves this connection with people and
ideas and information is going to be cleaner and quicker.
I don't know what form that's going to take in,
but all I'm doing is sort of objectively extrapolating what's happened in the
past to what's happened recently to where I feel like it's going.
I just don't think you can hold this waterfall back.
I feel like there's too much going on.
There's too many people communicating to freely all over the world and improving
upon the methods of communication.
And they're going to get to a point where you're not going to be able to hide a
goddamn thing and you're not going to be able to make money off of,
you're gonna not gonna be able to profit of doing something that directly
damages the earth.
Cause everyone's gonna see it.
It's going to be,
it's going to be something that your neighbors know about.
It's going to be something that I,
we're going to know what each other were getting away with.
But don't you sink?
You end up with the guy slammed a kind of story where you can push a story and
maybe you twist 15% of the data to make it a little,
to make your point a little harder.
And somebody else based on that 15 or 20% of your making up debunk the whole
thing and say it's all crap.
And there's that part of the flow of information is that there's so much of it
that for every single thing you hear that seems to prove the sinks going one
way.
F people seem pretty credible who give you good evidence to argue the exact
opposite things and he leaves a ton of human beings feeling like,
uh,
what the fuck?
I don't know which one of them to believe they these ones sound good.
This one also makes sense.
I feel like we're either going to go one way or the other.
We're either going to go slide into complete total dictatorship brought out by a
series of terrorist events or we're going to slide into the next level of
evolution and I think it's a battle right now.
What does that quote from Orson Welles history?
History is,
Goddammit,
I forget the quote,
amazing court by Orson Wells,
but essentially w to paraphrase it,
what is saying is that there's a race going on between people who were looking
to improve the human race and people that are stuck in the old paradigm that are
constantly battle between education and,
fuck.
God dammit.
I hate when,
I don't remember a great quote that I think I have at my fingertips need to
quote board here up on the walls,
his story,
Orson Welles human history becomes more and more a race between education and
catastrophe narratives.
One and that's exactly what it is.
I mean that's exactly what
we're talking about.
I feel like the way things are going,
the what,
when you hear people like the NSA folks say that you know that the angry that a
guy like Edward Snowden released all the data and he's a trader and you know all
this craziness where you trying to convince us that this guy is bad because he
told us that you right.
Bad.
See why can I always see the dark side?
I want to come with you guys into the light.
I really do.
But see all I see happening is another nine 11 attack and then the people in the
Nsa going guess what allowed that one?
That was the stuff Edward Stoten told you.
Now see now don't you learn?
Trust us next time and you won't have another one of these.
I just,
you know,
I mean I think things could break in the right way,
but I think history shows that they're stacked up against us.
And so I think if you take this attitude that hey,
things could break the right way,
you are not girding yourself up for the fight that you're facing.
And this gets back to what we talked about when you talked about fights.
If you think,
oh that George Foreman,
I'm about to fight,
ah,
he's got openings,
I watched him and taping it,
that is left is slow,
I'll get in on that.
And then you,
you don't account for the right and you get in there and you go,
oh damn,
I forgot about that.
I think you need to gird yourself and say,
history shows that there's always a small group of people you know who have a
little bit of the ear of the powerful or who have a little bit more money or
what have you,
and they're extremely formidable.
There's never going to be like,
we all get this consciousness expansion and Dick Cheney's never getting anywhere
near government.
Again.
The truth is we're playing Black Hawk down and Dick Cheney's busy,
you know,
buying up corporations and I just,
I think this is a monumental struggle that's going to require,
you know,
what's missing,
and I've always said this is we don't have any leaders.
I mean in other generations you can name people,
you can Wikipedia and search people that were out in the forefront,
bringing groups of people in two directions.
I feel like we were a very directionless group except for Putin.
Dan Carlingford precedent,
and that's what you want.
That's when you really see how limited the person I am.
I'm already at the height of my game.
I don't get any better than this.
So you put me up to president and it's all over.
Then the reviews on iTunes will be horrible
guy like Putin is like one of the last real leaders and a leader in a very
gangster
Moorish sort of way,
but still isn't where the old,
he's old school as old school as it gets.
Yeah.
I mean the guy was the president and they say,
you can't be present anymore.
He goes,
all right,
I'll be a prime minister.
This guy's the president now fuck heads.
Oh No,
it's on the president again.
He is kind of showing a blueprint for how you take a new democracy and just kind
of,
and,
and the people wanted a democracy and you just kind of convinced them that the
way you're doing it is better.
And you interview these people in the street,
they go,
oh,
Russia really needs a strong man.
Really.
When did you get convinced to that?
Where's your awareness or raising level and everything?
Um,
just to,
to
play devil's advocate for what you said earlier when you were talking earlier
about,
uh,
you see it going in a bad direction.
We were just talking at the beginning of this conversation how fucked up things
were just a few hundred years ago.
Like how much worse things were 500 years ago.
How much is that really correct where they really that much worse?
And if that's true,
then isn't there some sort of a marked improvement in society and the safety and
society that we can demonstrate today?
Well,
the first and the situation was better back then.
Yeah,
the cold,
the water was all clean,
different,
different things were messing up the water,
pick that shit and everything.
That's right.
And bodies,
they tossed bodies in there.
Yeah.
I mean there's always been people doing stupid shit to the ground because they
had short term interest at stack.
That's a very good point.
That point that you had about people looking at it and it,
and also back in the day,
I mean up until recently you didn't really live long enough to see the hustle.
Right.
You know,
if you were lucky,
you live to be 30 ish,
you know a good 50% of your friends are probably dead by then.
And then you know the guys that would live to be 60 those rare birds,
it would be hanging around philosophizing and square.
They were so rare that we really didn't get that many of them.
So when you got a guy like Socrates had dropped all this crazy knowledge like
yeah,
that guy had been around a long time.
He made,
he made through,
wrote some shit down and figured it out.
Most people not going to get there.
Most 25 year olds today are half retarded.
Try having a conversation with the average 25 year old.
Don't worry.
Their awareness is going to compensate for that and believe you me,
I know that a lot of you out there that are 25 are way fucking smarter than me.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm not saying it's you,
but you know those other dudes,
Joe Bird in the hand is worth two in the bush.
That's the proverb that applies to this whole short term thing.
If you think,
I might not even be alive to profit off this stuff,
but I can profit off it today,
what are you going to know about that?
I mean,
back then you're dealing with like a whole society that was sort of structured
on people that never got old enough or never had exposure to enough data to,
to sort of go,
ah,
I don't think we should have a Caesar.
I don't think we should have this coliseum.
Hey,
this whole lions versus Christians thing,
this is kind of fucked man.
Let's not to that.
But that's what I Dorson was cool.
It was so cool with,
because that's exactly what it t's.
He's the ugly side,
easy,
insanely strong and in some way getting stronger.
The potential for optimism there also that's also happening and it's one of
those racist where you're like,
hmm,
that's an interesting one.
You can put the accent on either one.
The reality is that they are both real well sort of what we were also talking
about about competition earlier,
that the Yin and the Yang.
It's almost like you need opposing forces.
You need a pull and a push.
You need something in order to motivate change.
It's almost the idea is that in order for society to get great or get better and
it has to go through stupid shit and if it doesn't go through stupid shit,
it never gets anywhere.
That's great.
I'm curious for,
I had a question for Dan on that because I don't,
these are gonna be your review.
I mean there is a law.
You're allowed to.
Don't worry.
I'm okay.
Everybody else does.
No.
But no,
I actually most days that's exactly I feel,
and even
the days that I don't,
I still feel that there's a lot of it.
That's true.
So the point to me is how do you turn that awareness that our stock up against
some seeing,
you know,
Yara Nan to trying to attack a tank.
You know,
you are the odds.
What you can do,
not even as it needs single individual,
but even in mass level feel sometimes so limited.
And uh,
ow do you wake up in the morning,
you know,
how do you deal with the Fed that you have a lot of armies drinks,
whiskey powers down double espresso shots.
Some of that is true.
I actually talk about this on our political show because when you feel the most
upset about things in the most powerless,
you start to wonder about the wisdom of caring about this stuff.
And you look at people who don't.
I mean,
I think we all know people who don't pay any attention to politics,
who don't watch the news,
whose life is a very,
you know,
it's my kids,
it's my wife,
it's my job.
And,
and,
and there are times when I questioned the wisdom of caring about things you
cannot change.
Then someone else will say,
well,
the,
that kind of attitude,
you can be guaranteed.
You won't change it.
Yes.
But there are some forces at work that if you alone have to do it,
it is an ant against a tank.
Right?
And,
and,
and at some point you look and you go,
okay,
it's me and Rogan and Danieli and,
and,
and that's not enough.
I might as well do what I can.
What's the,
in the 1960s he used to say,
you know,
Oh,
look at the man in the mirror.
Take care of yourself first.
Sometimes that's all you can control.
But if that's the way you look at it,
you're letting the Dick Cheney's I'm using him as my,
my,
my Darth Vader figure for everything today.
But I mean,
then you let them win.
Could you imagine if you've got Dick Cheney high on mushrooms?
I'm not sure it,
that he wasn't the whole time explaining some things.
He would never have that sort of the mushrooms.
You thought he shot that friend of his just totally sober and straight.
Oh,
who's drunk?
Okay,
well,
well he's clearly not.
He was,
not only was he drunk and not clearly drinking,
but he avoided the police for like 13 or 14 ounces.
There weren't secret service guys there too.
How do you not tell him to push and put the gun down pointed toward the ground?
That's how you know how,
what a real gangster is.
He shot his friend in the face and his friend apologize.
Yeah.
That is actually very good.
That is a good at his friend was like,
I'm really sorry.
Dick's a great guy.
I didn't mean to cause you all this trouble with the medium.
Mr Cheney,
my facing the path of your bullet.
I'll try to bird like in my movement,
I'm tricky.
I think like a bird sometimes in a hunting birds and he'd probably tuned into
that vibe.
She shot me in my fucking therapist.
There've been times that I've been,
you know,
we just carrying the weapon quite wrong and not,
where's the secret service to take credit for that?
Why didn't they say they accidentally shot the dude?
Why the fuck did you tell if they're willing to take a bullet for somebody?
How did that go?
How'd the guy not say accidentally shot himself?
But nothing that happens.
Right?
So it doesn't matter.
It's not a bird shot in the face.
You know,
birds shot is very small people.
I'm not saying try,
try a wad and you've got a few mannequins that we could conduct
some experiments on.
You know,
how does that alien thing handled the bird shot?
Well,
there's a reason why it's so small.
When you're shooting to something like a pheasant,
you can't really shoot it with a fucking 12 gauge.
It'll blow a hole through the cruise,
the meal up to later useless.
You filled,
it's filled with little pellets.
The fucking half the thing is blown apart.
So you've got to have like a little,
so that's what the old guy got hit with just a little baby bird shot in the
face.
No biggie.
Tough it out.
Now Dick's got a new heart and that's hilarious.
What do imagine if you had a new heart and then they put it in and he just
started fucking feeling really regretful for everything and started writing.
Did you hear the line?
He said that he hit and I didn't read the story.
Sometimes I just read headlines so you just have to ignore me on this.
But,
but do you remember that story about Dick Cheney where he said he feared having
these heart hacked or whatever?
Of course he did because he knew because he knew what he would have done in the
same situation.
Luli I'm hacking Joe Rogan's heart right now,
which leads me to believe you and I had exchanged a couple of tweets and emails
regarding this Michael Hastings thing.
Fascinating.
That whole story was Michael Hastings,
the journalist who was very aggressive towards members of the military and uh,
he was aggressive toward everybody.
Yes.
Very aggressive and aggressive towards like these guys who are fucking killers
on a global scale.
You know,
when you get to be a four star general or what have you,
like you're fucking real good at killing people.
You know,
there's no other way around it.
No other way to get to that.
And this guy was being aggressive towards them.
Have you changed your mind?
I have you altered your view on that hall?
I have zero opinion.
I don't have an opinion one way or the other.
I looked at it,
watched the video of the car slamming into the tree and I thought,
wow,
that was most likely,
uh,
you know,
some sort of a,
a remote control device that caused him to slam.
That's when I started reading that.
People said that.
But I've also read that a lot of people believe that he was unstable and a lot
of people believe that he might've been doing drugs.
And that's possible too.
I mean,
the kind of guy who was so risk taking that he's willing to go after generals,
like that Kinda guy might do a lot of wild shit.
Right.
I think it's possible though,
that they can do that to a car.
I think that's what I've gained from this.
What I've gained from this is by reading the experts,
the technology experts,
that people that have no vested interest in this politically one way or the
other,
we're in a Hastings fan or Denier,
the people that looked at the possibilities for what you can do with a remote
control system in a car now.
And they can do it.
They can,
they can make your car do things.
And the people that are formerly in the CIA have come out about it and said that
they believe that the technology exists and it makes sense,
right?
Even before it exists.
The,
remember the guy who had done all the exposing of the CIA crack cocaine
epidemic,
like basic called accusing the CIO for heavy now with the Latin American drug
lords weapon to be their friends.
Which guys is very seal.
You know,
I can't fucking remember the name.
I just don't remember that he was,
um,
he owns the ray quarter for IVN quote,
killed himself
by shooting himself with a shotgun.
So far,
nothing strange twice,
which seems a bit complicated to pull off.
The most interesting thing about the Hastings thing to me now,
because I can't,
I,
I'm,
I'm with you.
I don't know what you could figure out from Hastings based on what we know.
I was fascinated and this gets to your new media thing,
all the information out there and it also gets to yours,
uh,
Daniella about about false information or muddying the waters.
Do you realize how much of what circulated the glow about this Hastings thing
came from that one source,
that part time contributor to that local news station in San Diego that Kim
devor act a woman,
she's the one who said things like,
wow,
there was no body in the coffin.
And everyone was upset with that.
Well that turned out to be totally false,
but oh my lord.
Did we all share that?
And did everybody hear that?
Most people not ever hear the retracted,
that one person sang something that was not true.
Created that so much of the foundation for where we all started.
Cause that's when I freaked out and I said,
wait a minute.
You know,
the coroner didn't give the body back and cremated it without permission.
That is tea.
If you've ever dealt with coroners and that's just not kosher.
And that turned out to be turned out to be not true.
And I don't think she ever retracted it but,
but the one,
you know,
in the old days they used to make us confirm sources twice.
She's in the position where she's supposed to be confirming sources twice.
She says that the San Diego News station runs it multiple times and then we all
retweet it and share it and it becomes part of the urban legend almost.
But that,
that,
that a single strand one person was able to do that with the global sharing and
everything.
That to me is as fascinating as the Hastings thing.
I agree.
I think it's just as fascinating.
Uh,
and the,
the,
the real desire to know one way or another is just a natural part of human
curiosity.
We want to know that someone assassinate this guy or did he go wacky and drive a
hundred miles an hour into a tree?
Both are possible.
The reality is,
I don't know.
And so you know,
I say when you say,
did I change my opinion?
I don't have an opinion.
When I first looked at it and I said,
wow,
that looks like that,
but I wouldn't be betting on it.
Right.
You know,
a lot of weird shit happens.
Just naturally
get rid of.
There's another element,
Joey,
and the element is is an US versus them kind of thing.
Right?
I mean we felt people like yours truly.
Anyway.
It felt like Hastings was on our side of the fence.
Right.
He's reporting on stuff that we're going,
thank goodness finally somebody is doing this right.
And then all of a sudden he's gone.
And in a weird situation,
I mean I think the tendency is to say,
one of our guys got it in the neck and he got it in the neck for doing something
that we've been waiting for someone to do.
And what does this say to the other people out there?
We would hope would so,
I mean,
I don't,
I wouldn't want to say teams,
but there's a part of me that says to me,
I don't know if I would have liked the guy on a personal level,
but he was on my side and I feel like God,
the powers that be,
have everybody on their side.
I mean,
so,
so I mean,
there was a feeling like,
please tell me that somebody working for the good of all of us didn't get
knocked off.
I don't think he did.
But there's certainly that where you just go,
what sort of a message to descend to other would be Michael Hastings is,
you don't think he did,
but would you be
prize if you found out he did?
If he did get not,
you found out he got knocked out.
I wouldn't be.
There's a book called poisoning the press,
um,
concerning a reporter who was the Michael Hastings of his day,
but a thousand times bigger named Jack Anderson from the early seventies.
And Anderson actually had the Nixon administration officials,
Haldeman Ehrlichman,
those guys talking about potentially killing him.
Um,
um,
a guy who show I was on several times,
g Gordon Liddy,
ah,
Liddy was volunteering to kill him.
They were going to run him over with a car.
Now I always think to myself,
okay,
so the,
so the plot never happened,
but they were discussing it at the highest levels of government and that's what
makes you go,
maybe this Hastings thing isn't that far off the wall.
I mean,
I don't think it's far off the wall at all.
I just don't know what happened.
Yeah,
no,
me either.
I'm not at all.
And I tend to go with the safer answer when in doubt.
I mean that's the nice way of not looking stupid too,
which is of course my goal in life.
Right.
That's too late.
Too late.
Exactly.
Me Too.
So I just dive right into the stupid side all the time because the,
what if is always there.
That's what they're grading us on a curve.
Well,
that's the on an unfortunate reality of history,
isn't it?
That if you really do pay attention and go,
wow,
they've done it before.
Well,
there's been consumed.
You know,
people can inspire.
They've gotten away with it.
They did.
They did false flags.
They lied to get us into wars.
They lied about a certain actions that were going on.
They SAS unaided people lied about that and then got caught and they had a short
term in south.
Same thing.
Yes.
Always.
Always has been.
The thing that's weird is though when people are doing the exact opposite of
what we're doing right now,
which is,
you know,
he could have gone this way.
It could have also,
or at least a Culligan this way.
I don't have the evidence either way.
Uh,
and people bad their lives one way or another.
Yeah,
I know what a disease,
what happened and there's these conspiracy or no,
you're totally full of shit.
He could never happen.
And he's like out the fuck that you know.
I got a out of an argument online the other day on my message board about the
JFK assassination.
I get to that when I just go,
okay,
I'm good.
I got to step away.
I know too much about the JFK assassination.
I've studied it for far too long and it drives me absolutely fucking bonkers
when I see people that are 100% convinced that Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone,
right?
I'm like,
I don't know if we Harvey Oswald acted alone,
but guess what?
Fuck face you don't either.
And the reality of the evidence is not that cut and dry.
The Warren Commission itself as a massive contradictions.
It was clearly designed to achieve a predetermined conclusion and they ignored
all evidence that went contrary to that predetermined conclusion.
And that conclusion was there was a single shooter.
Are we going to go into this?
Is this,
are you opening this topic for discussion?
Not I'm not.
My message board will love.
My point is,
is
that when I see people argue,
I don't know if he acted alone and he might've acted alone.
I leave that open.
But when you see that stupid bullet that supposedly went through both of their
bodies and shattered bone and came out looking all pretty and beautiful,
you're like,
get the fuck Outta here.
Well that just showed up on governor Connally's Gurney at the,
at the hospital.
It just magically was there in perfect shape and just happened to be from the
same rifle.
The you're attributing to the guy who's dead now who got shot by a fucking mob,
man.
Come on
now.
I have to jump.
I changed my mind on this subject.
Look at that bullet,
Dan Carlin.
I've seen the magic bullet pile.
And you know what's funny is that I,
I don't dispute any of those things.
What if the government had a really good reason that you would have approved of
to kill a cop,
not to cover it up.
And we're doing a podcast on the first world war right now.
And Kennedy was famous for having given the guns of August,
the book that's about to lead into world war one and how nations were kind of
sucked into something they didn't want to do based on an assassination of a
world leader sitting in an open car next to his wife,
by the way.
Um,
and,
and if you're Lyndon Johnson and your,
the people around Kennedy and it's a year after the Cuban missile crisis,
right?
You almost have world war three a year ago and a guy kills a young popular
president in front of his wife who was,
you know,
in there and in the Chanel close with the blood and brains all on her and his
children are orphaned and you're mad as hell.
And the guys tied to communism like nothing.
I mean,
he's fair play for Cuba Committee.
He's one of the few people who defected to the Soviet Union.
He's one of the very few that came back.
Would you maybe be worried that the American people would be so angry and so
ready to somehow punish the communists who may have even been behind this
attack?
I mean there's,
you can create a scenario where it might've been a national security interests.
Two,
as much as you can disassociate Cuba,
communism,
and the Soviet Union from the assassination of the president.
Because even if it didn't happen,
can you see the Republicans and the administration back then going,
we need to do,
you can't let them get away with potentially shooting our president was not to
invade Cuba.
What?
I mean,
I'm a little confused
plying that you think that they made it look like Lee Harvey Oswald didn't do it
because if he did do it,
then that's communism killing the process.
No,
I think,
I think what most of us won't,
when I was on the side saying that,
I think there was a conspiracy is you point to all the obvious things the
government hit and that that to me is always a red herring.
Right?
You said where they hid the magic bullet couldn't have been this and that,
and then you start to think,
well,
would there have been a good reason for a government coverup?
Well,
the first good reason is because they did it right.
So you go,
well bastards.
Could there be a reason where you would sit there and go,
oh no,
I understand why you did that.
You did that to prevent a greater evil,
and I'm not saying that that's the case,
but once you sit back and do that,
you go,
there could be multiple reasons.
So you're saying
blame it on Lee Harvey Oswald instead of blaming it on the Cuban?
No,
I try to obscure the idea that this was something involving communist Cubans and
I think,
can you imagine if Oswald had actually had to take the stand someday and testify
about this and talk?
I mean this may have been the thing where the government said,
listen,
this is just one guy who did this,
but it's going to open up a whole can of worms with the political opposition.
I mean,
remember there were,
there were posters of John F.
Kennedy saying wanted for treason in Dallas the day he was killed,
that the right wingers down there had pushed.
What do you think they would say of Lee Harvey Oswald is tied to communism so
closely a year after we just avoided world war three that's a really stoned
idea.
I think you must've been hitting a bong hardcore
and you decided to do multiple angles,
baby.
Hey,
you may be right.
I mean,
look,
I'm not asserting that.
I'm saying you got to throw it into the minute you do.
It's probably a lot of way the game where you throw all the other stuff into the
middle.
The Grassy Knoll Ruby
had a direct connection to the mob.
The mob had a direct connection to Cuba.
Those three things are,
that's a fact.
Those are facts and so Jack Ruby was assigned to go kill Lee Harvey Oswald in
front of the police,
thus sacrificing his own freedom to do so that he knew he was doing it while he
was doing it.
It was a total suicide bombing.
The that's that alone is a direct connection to Cuba.
Yeah.
I'm old for a,
you know what does that noise?
I'm hearing it to someone's car alarm.
I'm just glad your studio is not a whole lot better than mine.
It stopping noise.
It has to be something like car for us to hear it,
but how fucking dumb are car alarms?
Nobody goes out and looks when they were first made people like this is,
it is gonna be no more theft.
They're going to hear this alarm and everyone's going to run out with a gun.
Now what?
He'd run,
nobody fucking pays any attention to car alarms anymore.
They yell out,
shut it off.
Like if you're an apartment building and it's going out,
people open up their window and yell out,
shut it off.
That's all they don't,
they don't yell out someone's breaking into your car.
They don't believe in it.
Yeah,
they'll cry wolf too many fucking times.
I gotta go out.
What you are saying though,
cause
I'm old for thinking from multiple directions,
but I stick with Joe's theory about the bank called that day because now I get
to
the,
um,
what Joe was saying is an objection on the idea that he foot yard trying to
avoid the communist go natural and to avoid world war three wine,
the ward.
Diane,
would you want everybody to know that the guy responsible is a guy who has come
in.
It's called an action.
You know what I stuck with that.
I mean,
you know,
if they capture Oswald and they arrest him,
you're stuck.
The trial.
If there's going to be a trial is going to bring all this out and imagine that
trial would have taken a year,
would have been on TV.
The people are just going to fume,
you know,
the communist things going to be brought up by the prosecution.
I,
you know,
I guess what I'm trying to say is I tried to figure out,
we always assume that when government covers up,
it's,
it's just hide something from us.
We'll be angry about.
Are there ever occasions where they cover something up because we would want to,
if we were in the same position for the good things.
Are there ever times when government covers stuff up for a good reason
to think they're smart enough to do that?
I really don't.
Well,
you might be right.
I think that this Lee Harvey Oswald case would,
it may very well be is one of the best examples possible that we're living in a
simulation because it's so Thea Nick Bostrom's idea.
Yes.
So theatrical,
I don't know how many people have had that idea,
but a lot of like really legit.
Oh yeah,
they and they,
they actually have a mathematical formula that says it's more possible than not
that we are.
If you look at the,
if you just look at the progression of technology and you think like where is it
eventually going to go a thousand years from now,
10,000 years from now,
it's inevitable.
If we don't blow ourselves up,
we're going to be able to recreate reality and it will be completely in the ant
farm.
We live in it,
but here's the way you know it.
We already play games on our computers that are really,
really primitive versions of that already.
If somebody came out you said,
hey,
we've got the brand new version of sieve and this time you'll have real people.
I mean,
you'd be like,
how much is that?
I'm on that right now.
That's why it leaves that opening.
Like if that was real,
where would it be?
And if it was here already,
would we know?
If you're gonna make an indiscernible,
how do you not know?
It's not already there.
And then there's things that are just so dramatic and so ridiculous like the
Kennedy assassination.
So such a perfect piece of theater,
the way it ties up so loosely and leaves you with a bunch of confusing facts.
And how about the fact that within the decade after the assassination,
more than a hundred witnesses to the crime or dead,
like some of them died,
they were murdered,
people die in car accidents and strange diseases and there were poisoned.
And I mean the odds are staggering that that would happen,
that a hundred people who saw the assassination would die.
And you don't think that governments smart enough to do this,
but they're smart enough to murder people.
That's pretty easy to do,
I think.
I think if you're good at defense,
they ever see you gotta you gotta go one way or the other.
Either they're really competent or they're really income,
either one.
It's just tying up loose ends.
I don't think that requires an extreme amount of intelligence.
I think the average person knows that if someone out there knows something that
they shouldn't know or they can contribute to some sort of a case that you
believe might be coming down and eventually put people that you know in jail,
the people that are hiring you in jail,
if there's some way to stop that data from being shared,
that what?
That's how you cut it off,
cut it off by killing the people.
There were witnesses.
That's pretty how to people they should have still killed then that they didn't
get.
That's true because they killed a hundred.
I mean,
let's killed a hundred people.
Yeah.
Let's assume that they actually did it.
If it more than a hundred witnesses were dead within a decade.
Well you should've gotten some of those guys right in those books that sold so
many copies,
get them early.
Yeah.
I mean,
and by the way,
just in the sense of,
uh,
the interest of fairness there,
there have been arguments against this Arrow Posner and,
and this bull Yossi both wrote good books on the other side of that.
Um,
yeah,
but not that good.
Those books were not that you didn't like?
No.
I thought you were both parties thought they did not leave open the possibility.
First of all,
they did not leave open the possibility for conspiracy and there the reality is
you do not know to call it case closed is nonsense.
If you weren't there,
if you didn't see it happen,
if you weren't a part of it,
I think you're guessing.
I think you're doing a lot of guests a shitload of gets all way,
but if you're guessing you can't say,
case closed,
you're full of shit.
Okay,
I see.
I see that point.
I can send that calling it case show.
The way those books were directed were very clearly directed in a presupposed
idea that Lee Harvey Oswald acted well.
They were written,
and this is the thing I always try to tell people is that don't read those
books.
If you don't know about the Kennedy's actually don't cause they're not directed
at you.
They're directed at people who already know a ton of it.
I loved.
It was one of the few books I've ever read where they didn't footnotes stuff.
They said,
you know,
you remember this book and they addressed other people's books without telling
you about them,
so you had to just,
they,
they figure you read all that stuff already they could address,
well,
Yossi is such a good prosecutor though.
He told me on the phone,
he said,
he said it would have been a slam dunk convicting ons.
That doesn't mean anything.
No,
it does.
If you're saying,
does that mean he could absolutely.
It just making it about it as a person trying to win a game.
He's not thinking about it as a person trying to find the truth.
The reality of the truth is he doesn't know.
I don't know.
You don't know that's true.
They're the only people that know are the people that were there that played a
part in that murder or didn't,
whether it's Lee Harvey Oswald and other conspirators or the other conspiracies
and we and Lee Harvey Oswald being the Patsy that he claims he was,
whatever the combination of things where,
which whatever number was correct.
Those are the people that know everyone else.
There's a giant amount of guessing and to pretend there's not a giant amount of
guessing means you're an asshole if you're pretending that you've got it nailed
right,
you're an asshole.
It's just a fact.
And so the people that are arguing and online,
I mean I,
I'll argue it online as well,
but the people that actually believe that they know for a fact one way or the
other,
it's not true.
And the magic bullet theory,
it was a lot of problems with the way people describe it.
A lot of the,
the trajectory that the angles of the bodies wasn't nearly as magical,
the path they were attributing to,
if you look at the fact that Kennedy was above him,
that the seat was actually raised and that Connolly was actually leaning and
turning around in the idea of there,
what's much more damning is Connolly's fucking testimony himself.
That he was not hit first and that when Kennedy was hit,
he turned around and then he heard the gunshots and then he was hit afterwards.
His own testimony refutes the idea of the magic bullet far better than anything
else.
When you see commonly talk about the series of events and how it played out
inside the limousine,
he throws the magic bullet out the window,
right?
The reason why they came up with the magic bullet theory in the first place,
because they had a tribute,
there was a bullet that hit a curb stone underneath the overpass.
They had to attribute a bullet that Lee Harvey Oswald shot or someone from that
direction of Lee Harvey Oswald shot to that bullet cause that ricocheted and hit
a man and the guy went to the hospital.
So because of that,
then they had to come up with one bullet doing all this damage.
It doesn't mean it's logical ballistics or weird though Joe bullets do weird
things.
They do do weird things and know what they don't.
And when you talk about witnesses in a car,
remember this is than the speed of sound.
The sound hits at a different,
I mean it's 100% it's a little weird,
right?
You're absolutely right.
However,
the,
if you look at the possibilities,
is it possible that a bullet hit these two bodies and smashed bone?
Did very little damage actually left more fragments inside the bullet?
Then we're missing from the bullet?
Is that possible?
I don't know.
I mean he could have had a freak bullet that had like extra shit on it and that
maybe maybe they're attributing certain thing.
Maybe it's poor science and they're attributing certain things to being pieces
of the bullet that weren't actually pieces of bullet,
but the odds are that that was not a bullet that smashed bone.
If you've ever seen what a bullet looks like when it hits bone,
it doesn't look like that.
Can it look like that?
Man,
and I may be under some really freaky circumstance,
but that's the aberration.
That's not the norm.
The norm is a bullet distorts wildly when it hits bone.
That's part of what they're designed to do.
They're designed to break up inside the body and do more damage to designed to
hit things and spread out.
You know what polio season Posner's book though did that I thought was fantastic
and it goes back to that Kim Devorah,
Michael Hastings thing,
we talked about it a minute ago.
They showed what a lot of the conspiracy writers deliberately left out of their
work because it messed up their theories making.
One of the big pieces of evidence that that really kind of changes a lot of
mines is the idea that Oswald took a shot at the general in the weeks before he
shot president or maybe allegedly shot Prezi and when you realize he's,
he's out there trying to kill people already makes him look a lot less like a
patsy and a lot more like a guy who was,
God,
I missed the general,
hey,
guess what,
president Kennedy's coming in a motorcade and I work in a building along the
route.
I guess I remember myself being upset with some of these conspiracy authors
whose work I like because they left this out and I remember thinking,
what?
That bastard left this out.
He knew that this was there,
but it makes us theory look bad and he left it out.
That's where I started to get real angry at people whose work you're reading
because you want to believe it and trust it.
That's a very good point and there's is certainly possible and but you know
what?
It's also not an either or.
I agree with all supply.
Agree with the Harvey Oswald acted in conjunction with some other people.
There's a lot of variables.
Many people wanted the president dead.
Well,
that's the real issue.
The real issue is did did the president at the time create enough enemies where
they were a gang of people that wanted him dead and that is uncontroversial,
right?
I think so.
Wait,
now I'm leaving.
Going to say in controversial.
Well,
because here's the thing that I think Oliver Stone did a great job of distorting
was this idea that somehow president Kennedy had upset the military industrial
complex and all of this guy,
when in reality the guy had just done the biggest peacetime military buildup in
American history.
He had just re remember he campaigned on something called the missile gap.
So when he got the job,
he increased military spending by a ton,
but he's still wanting to get out of Vietnam.
He didn't really want to get out of Vietnam and he was going to move assets to
Laos and Cambodia.
Uh,
I guess my point is,
is that he was not an enemy of those very forces that Oliver Stone had him being
the enemy of.
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
He,
he was a hawk,
but was it that black and white?
No,
no,
no.
It was not that black and white.
It was not.
And you don't know what other things they may have wanted that he was pushing
back on and see.
We just don't know what you didn't know that he said he wanted to get rid of the
Federal Reserve.
How don't know enough about that.
I can't,
I can't comment intelligently on that.
I mean,
I,
I can't eat comment intelligently on almost everything I say,
but it doesn't stop a stop at the membrane.
Some of us are more competitive.
They have k federal bank.
But I mean that's the thing though.
That's when you,
what's funny about these arguments is when you see people who are really good at
pushing forward all the evidence,
supporting their conclusion and the staff that doesn't fit with their
conclusion,
it's not there.
It's like poop.
I just for you,
just the same thing that he accused the government are doing right?
Hiding and omissions and all that stuff and that's why you read one book and
you're like,
it looks really convincing and all the points they are making,
it looks pretty good.
And then you're like,
wait,
why the hell did you leave this stuff out?
And when you find out they leave it out,
you start to distrust them to absolutely.
I don't trust the government or some of those conspiracy writers.
The idea,
the conspiracy theories site theorist site is this executive order one one one
one zero and this was issued by Kennedy on June 4th of 1963 and this executive
order are delegated to the secretary of the treasury of the president's
authority to issue silver certificates under the Thomas Amendment of the
Agricultural Adjustment Act as amended by the Gold Reserve Act and the order
allow the secretary to issue silver certificates,
if any word needed during the transition period under president Kennedy's plan
to eliminate silver certificates.
So the idea was that he was moving in on the institution known as the Federal
Reserve because the Federal Reserve,
as most people realize,
isn't really a federal kind of a thing at all.
It's it's,
it's not a part of the government.
Oh look,
it's the horn again.
Hopefully the police are on their way to stop this dastardly person from
stealing someone's pens and change.
You didn't even have car radios.
He can steal anymore.
They're all integrated into the system.
We'll see me if you're not going to steal a car.
And if you do steal a car,
good luck trying to fucking hide it.
Everyone's got a goddamn gps in their car now.
Yes.
Stupid fuck.
So the idea that they,
uh,
espouse is that,
um,
this was the executive order that s that started the beginning of the end.
I've also seen a lot of people say that they think Lyndon Johnson had something
to do.
Somebody just sent me that book.
I haven't looked at it yet,
but the Lyndon Johnson killed out a kid killed Kennedy book or something.
Is it a new one that's out?
I had Jesse Ventura on my show a couple of times and now I get it and now I get
all those books without even asking,
Oh,
you poor bastard.
It's bad.
I,
um,
I did a with the people that did his show and uh,
you know,
there was a couple of times when we had like these sort of discussions about
conspiracies and you know what's,
and I'm like,
you know,
they're all juicy and salacious,
but the idea that if you look at too many things as being in conspiracy,
you do a huge disservice to what might actually be a conspiracy by playing into
the hands of the Phoenix Zack,
whether you realize it or not,
I mean to be like a crazy right wing radical like the fire and brimstone sort of
a guy you played directly into the hands of the government to slam me.
I'm getting this slam,
like I'm an anti conspiracy person and they were all saying Dan Carlin edge,
somebody even wrote a review on Itunes,
said something like he doesn't understand how the world works and he's just
giving you the pablum mine.
Yeah.
But there are conspiracies out there,
but like you said,
you do yourself a disservice when you buy all of them.
Dan Carlin,
you got to stop listening to critics these topless,
and I was telling me,
Joe was telling me that before the show,
he goes to listen to anybody.
Listen,
you can learn things from people's criticism is good.
I've learned a lot from people's criticism,
but you also have to understand human nature and there's a lot of people out
there that are sad as fuck and they want you to feel sad too.
We want you to hurt and instead,
I mean it's cause their water is liable on fire and flammable and yours isn't.
It could be that.
It could be the number one to fuck them.
I'm going with the ladder.
Most of the time it's no one wants to fuck them and you have a deficit.
You have a desire for attention.
They'd put that in the review.
Then let's,
let's,
I'm probably only saying this because I'm 496 pounds.
I Shit my pants on a daily basis.
No one's touched me in a decade that [inaudible] doesn't know shit about how the
world works that suck these out.
They're confusing us.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
I think that you can get a lot out of it is in terms of a,
you can get other people's eyes.
I think it's helped me a lot with my standup.
It's helped me a lot.
Even negative criticism.
I go,
okay,
I can see how you see that.
I think it's good.
It fires you up,
makes you want to perform better.
It makes you want to,
you know,
analyze things with under a more critical eye,
under a Nada,
Nada,
not indoctrinated.
I,
I think it's good,
but I also think you've got to know when to listen to them and when not to.
When someone says,
Dan Carlin doesn't know how to work to go.
All right.
Do you think it shuts people down?
We were talking about why more people don't,
don't get ahead and the competition thing.
I think that kind of criticism does shut some people down where they're just,
they,
they're,
they're not,
they can't,
I mean obviously we all can handle it cause we all do something where we're
criticized on a daily basis.
But I mean,
I think there's some people that just,
they don't want,
my boss does it,
but I don't want it in public.
I was reading a thing the other day,
it's just,
I've been railing on about this lately about the idea of people are,
are going on about what they're calling for fat shaming and fat shaming is
making people feel bad for being overweight.
And I've read this one article where this woman was talking about how she was
being fat shamed because she went to a family function and everyone was gushing
about cousin.
Her cousin lost 20 pounds and the that they were making such a big deal out of
it,
that it was clear to her that they were judging her for not losing the 20
pounds.
So it made her feel awful and she didn't understand how they couldn't understand
that what they were doing was fat shaming her by complimenting someone on losing
weight,
you're fat shaming the person who hasn't lost the weight and that it made her
feel awful and that it was incredibly insensitive of them.
And that,
you know,
I'm fascinated by that kind of thinking.
I really am.
I'm fascinated by that sort of like,
like reverse victimology sort of a thing where instead of you being the victim
of your own handiwork,
you become like a persecuted person because they don't accept you for the flaws
that you have or even mentioned the possibility of those flaws existing by
virtue of complimenting someone for having gotten over the same flaws that you
possess.
Hilarious.
I think without even knowing the specifics on us on particular issues,
anytime somebody,
so we'll link to embrace the victim role,
uh,
his mouth traveled right away and be like,
do you know there's a reality to losing weight that we have this Dave Asprey guy
who's an expert in a lot of aspects of nutrition.
He's a fascinating guy and one of the things he was talking about where he was
giving a overweight people a pass,
because you're saying the level of addiction that these people actually have for
food to say that they don't have willpower is really unfair because there are so
overweight.
Like a lot of these folks are so far gone that they used up all of their
willpower just to get up in the morning just to walk to the bus stop,
just to go,
go to work,
just to get their,
their,
their chores done during the day.
Like they don't have the same level of energy that a healthy person has.
So to attribute them to having like this,
there's this backlog of energy they're not tapping into because they're weak
willed.
It's not that like they're,
they're already so far in the hole.
It's almost impossible for them to get motivation.
They have to get something like incredibly extreme has to happen to them.
And I thought that was really unique.
And,
and looking at that west people to say,
yes,
people out of shade,
people who are depressed,
you could see the in with people that are ruining their life too,
whether it's through addictions,
you know,
you see that as well.
It's like why can't they see it the way other people see it?
It's almost like they can't,
like,
they're so trapped up in the momentum of whatever it is,
whether it's gambling or food.
I mean,
I've seen people with food addictions that you can watch the gears spinning in
their mind when food is nearby.
Like they know they're supposed to lose weight and they know they're not
supposed to be eating it,
but the,
the gears start spinning in their mind and that becomes the primary focus of
their existence.
Get that fucking doughnut.
I need that donut.
That donut is huge.
It's,
it's,
it's critical for fueling whatever the whatever trouble is going on in their
mind and it's a weird aspect of human beings and you don't do that any favors by
pretending that encouraging someone who lost weight is a bad thing either.
The idea that
socially that's irresponsible because you're fat and you're near them.
No,
it's actually responsible because that terrible feeling that you have,
it's supposed to be the bump that pushes you towards eating a salad instead of a
cheeseburger should be the bump that makes you write down everything you're
going eat that day and state some goals.
This is what I'm going to do.
I'm going to use my willpower to overcome this horrible obsession that I have
with shitty food.
That's also possible.
It's also possible by by you going home and blaming everybody in the blog that
you've projected yourself away from any potential benefit from having these bad
feelings and game.
He's the same as the above.
The competition is somebody who never learned how to lose and the same in a
avoiding criticism like you gotta,
you gotta look at it.
It's a,
it feels like shit,
but that feel like shit.
Correct it so it doesn't feel like shit anymore.
I thought the show was very disorganized until you guys just tied it into a
beautiful bow like that.
It's all of a sudden got a theme that's running through it and planned it this
way.
Everyone had a finger.
There's a way to bring this bitch around all art form.
It is.
Oh,
most certainly is,
right.
I mean for sure.
Actually podcasting is an art form.
Look,
I tell everybody,
and I'll,
I'll say it,
even though you're here,
you're fucking podcast is one of my favorite things that I listened to,
one of my absolute favorite things.
It is a national treasure.
It's so interesting.
It educates people on aspects of history that were completely ignored and it
does in a really entertaining and dynamic way.
And it's so important,
dude.
Dude,
I did not.
Can I just tell you I don't get it.
I've never gotten it.
I've never ever gotten it.
You know,
just why you can do it.
That's why it's good.
I mean,
I'm grateful.
Don't get me wrong,
but,
but I've never quite seen it as others see it.
Oh,
it'd be,
that's good.
That's good goals.
That's what I,
you know,
I do.
I know that's how you got me.
Because I've been a fan of Mongo guy.
I've been a fan of chaos.
And so I was a young,
it's not a fucking coincidence.
And I'm a standup comedian and I'm also a cage fighting commentator.
That's true.
I mean,
it's,
that's not a coincidence.
I'm,
I've,
I'm a massive fan of chaotic events.
I'm a massive fan of this,
these explosive things that that throw the norm in the question and completely
change the paradigm of the,
the existing reality that we operate under.
And when you listen to something like a podcast on the mon goals,
it's like Jesus,
that was only the 12 hundreds there wasn't that long ago.
I forgot to bring this shirt.
I got this bad ass getting his con world tour shirt.
That's great.
A back.
It has all the fucking to towns that he sacked and although he better we're mode
now you got to send me a photo by you one,
I'll send it to you.
You owe me all these appearances I've done for you a bitch and I do.
We all know each other man,
but I,
I definitely owe you for many,
many,
many times I have to say,
I hope this doesn't embarrass you.
Did you read what that one comic set about being on Joe Rogan's podcast or
having Joe Rogan endorse him?
Was it bill burr or someone like that said,
you are the Oprah of podcasts.
We come on your show.
It just,
all of a sudden everything is rainbows and Unicorns us once we're on Joe
show,
which is true by the way.
But otherwise,
I mean the favor you've done to all the rest of us,
not to kiss anybody's ass here,
but it really is.
I mean you,
you've made a lot of people aware of what we do.
Well,
I'm honored
that I could do that,
but you know,
on my end,
from my perspective,
all I've done is let people know things that I found that are awesome.
That's not that difficult Joe Rogan book.
Well,
if you're honest,
if you're an honest person and I pride myself in being insanely honest to the
point where,
you know,
I'm,
I'm like one of the reasons why I'm really good at accepting criticism because I
am an insanely self critical.
I mean,
I'm good at avoiding going nuts.
I think I'm all are.
I think that's kind of what makes you,
you can't do what we do without being that.
I agree.
But,
um,
but my,
my recognition of the role,
um,
I'm aware of it.
I'm also a,
I'm honored and I,
I feel like without a doubt I have an obligation,
but I also feel like all I'm doing is letting people know about amazing shit
that already exists.
It's beautiful to be that sort of a conduit to be sort of a funnel point where
people can know they can a portal where they can go here and they can learn
about all sorts of cool shit.
But if the cool shit didn't exist,
I would have run out of things to talk about it a long time ago.
No,
that's through.
But it's also through the fact that that what you have done for so many pictures
on the reality is,
I mean when I think about un Dan Kahn,
for me in my life,
the impact that it does add coming onto your show and Dan Kuschell imparticular,
it's fucking hot in Rio.
You know,
so it's like,
that's why I always say as a joke,
but maybe not as a joke about it.
Like you guys ever need out moving around
bodies.
But again,
you know
what I mean?
It's important that you guys are out there.
You guys are out there providing us with an entertainment information and
entertainment form that expands my view of the world.
You're personally responsible for extent expanding my view of history above and
beyond where it would have ever been without you.
That's a fact.
And when I looked down and iTunes and I saw your show rising through the ranks,
I mean I've,
I was,
I was so happy for you.
So Oprah Book Club Picking Them Up.
Yeah.
What was the highest year he got on iTunes forth.
That's insane.
That's him.
All of it.
And that's your help,
baby.
What did you,
what were you and your listeners too,
by the way,
before you ever came on the show,
what was the highest he'd ever been?
We got up to like eight a long,
long time ago before we had any of this competition we have now.
You know,
and I don't know if folks understand that it is so competitive now.
There are so many things out.
There was so much promotion that that to reach 20th now is a bigger deal than
reaching seventh or eighth,
five or six years ago.
I mean it's,
yeah,
it's much more competitive.
But you know,
I mean we hover around 12th 14th 15th something like that.
The numbers of people making podcasts right now.
Crazy.
But I think that's a great thing.
Absolutely.
And I become an evangelist and I tell people all the time,
if you've ever thought about doing it,
you ought to try it.
Yeah.
Why not fuck up.
You never know.
I mean I would have never known.
I would have never
Joe,
I don't mean to say it's up to it to bring up a subject.
Maybe your whole audience already knows.
How did you get the idea to do this?
Well we started just putting it on a a on Ustream.
We got an idea.
So that was first.
Yeah.
Well actually before even used to Ustream,
there's a thing called Justin dot.
TV and we were on that and we would do,
we would broadcast from the green room and like take questions from the green
room and people enjoyed it.
It was fun.
But what made you think of eve?
I mean cause the idea of deciding to do it is such a,
especially back then,
it was such a weird step to take.
Well there was a lot of yeah.
People that had already done it.
Um,
Adam Carolla and current,
no Corolla didn't do it.
Did he?
Yeah,
he had done for me,
he had one straight from radio to doing it.
That was the first step.
So we had snow flakes on in the background and we just did on Ustream.
We didn't know what we're doing.
And I did it with Brian.
Um,
the,
uh,
we went from that to also opie and Anthony Opie and Anthony,
a great radio show on Sirius and their radio show is so similar to the way that
I started doing podcasts where it's just to hang,
it's just a conversation.
Right.
I mean sometimes I have questions for the guests.
Sometimes it's kind of structured in that way where there's some things that I
want to get to cause I know that you have an expertise in that area,
but a lot of it is just a bunch of people shooting the shit and just talking
honestly about life.
And I've always found that incredibly entertaining.
And Anthony started doing this thing out of his basement.
He set up this thing called live from the compound.
He's,
he's a nut.
He's a gun.
Nadia is like 50 caliber machine guns and shit.
And he put the green screen behind him and he was doing karaoke while he's
singing with a gun in his hand.
He's fucking crazy.
But I was like,
this guy's got like a professional studio set up in his basement.
And I'm like,
God damn it,
we should start doing something.
So we started doing it just on Ustream and then started putting it on iTunes.
And now in the end of next month,
it'll be four years.
And you know,
we're 400 plus episodes in.
Look what iTunes has done for,
for the whole,
you know what I thought the greatest thing they ever did for people like us was,
was not separating the ESPNs and the,
and the,
and the professional content from the stuff that we do because it allows us an
equal playing field in a way that if they said,
okay,
here's your professional stuff,
now here's your amateur stuff in this pile over here in this,
in this grab bag of singles.
Nobody wants,
I feel like in the same way that we just said,
you know,
I mean,
I owe you,
I owe iTunes.
There's a lot of people that made something possible here.
I don't know what I'd be doing anymore without a podcast.
I'm no longer a news reporter kind of guy.
I'm no longer a radio talk shows.
I'd be like janitor.
And I would be really bad at that too.
So I mean,
I,
there's a lot of people we owe for where we are today.
Uh,
no daisy.
Yeah.
And if there wasn't some sort of a form like Itunes,
we could just upload it to them and then people could download it from the RSS
and the hosting services and everything.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're number six right now in the world,
son.
Ah Jeez.
Six on.
I try to be making more money.
Don't you think?
Number six in the world getting fucked and you see what I drive here?
Sometimes I wonder if this is America and wonder if it's the u s it's got some
BBC stuff on there.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if it is a,
whether or not is actually the country or the world,
but whatever it is,
you're number six at of all podcasts.
I owe your audience and you know your audience is awesome by the
way.
I mean,
I hear from them and they always say the same thing I found out about you from
Joe Rogan.
Just so you know.
Find Cool Shit.
Don't lie to them.
That's it.
Yeah.
You find cool shit.
Be Honest.
To be honest about how you feel about things.
Don't,
don't be transparent in the way you mean.
Even when I talk,
like if I talk about something like the,
the magic bullet theory where I'll argue something,
the bottom line always is I will tell you exactly what I actually do know and I
don't know.
I don't know what happened.
You can't know.
Right.
And I think finding out about cool things and being honest about the and,
and,
and encouraging that sort of really objective discussion about things that
that's a,
that's the thing that we're missing.
That's the thing we're missing in our social circles to sit thing we're missing
in life.
People get attached to ideologies.
Yeah.
Like we were saying,
well people say one way or another and then just fucking argue it to death.
I know Michael Hastings was killed by then.
Your credibility is on the line and everything.
Yeah.
Whether it's big foot or fucking Ufos or being a Republican,
there's,
there's people that get on a fucking team and they will,
all those people were a problem.
Their problem to themselves.
They're a huge problem politically too.
Because as I said,
you know,
it doesn't hurt us that one party does something.
But then when we forgive it,
when our Party,
whatever party that might be gets in power,
there are Democrats who,
who if,
if George W.
Bush was doing what President Obama is doing would be out in the streets with
signs,
but then yes,
it's their guy they don't and vice versa.
That's such a good point and one that I really get on progressive's leftwing
people about,
um,
like your acceptance of war crimes done under a democratic administration.
The idea of the same exact things being done in the Republican administration
would be horrific war crimes and you,
the acceptance of them is so gross and so telling and codified the whole thing.
You were so against when the other guy was doing it because now you don't have a
leg to stand on.
When the Republicans get back in office,
do this,
what are you going to say?
You got to complain about it again.
Then it reinforces the idea of this being a fucking simulation and that that's
all design.
We're liking that idea more and more.
It's the Yin and Yang.
It's the theater.
It's the two party system.
It sounds like they brought in a fourth party,
but there's too confusing.
People didn't know what to follow anymore.
They start tuning into different channels.
So is that Perot character came along and fucking threw a big monkey wrench into
the whole situation.
It's too much.
Let's go back to two and a fringy.
That's why we haven't had a third person at those presidential debates since.
Yeah.
Well the commission for presidential debates,
a privately funded institution with half Democrats and half Republicans on their
staff.
It's hilarious and they try so hard to make sure that Weirdos don't get in the
Gary Johnson's of the world.
The people that are going to throw ask this though.
Why are they all Weirdos?
Because I keep feeling like that's almost like part of the rigged thing that if
you have somebody who has some ideas,
you go,
finally somebody's saying the right thing about this and they got,
let's go.
Go.
Yes,
but I'm also a secret clan member just so you know.
Why do they always have to come with some baggage like that you're not doing,
it might not be my Nazi newsletters from the past and I'll come to haunt me.
Right.
That the only type of people that have the balls to step out like that or
socially a little wacky for everybody else.
It's a big risk.
We talk about that.
Like if you're Anthony Wiener and you know there's more pictures out there but
you run any way knowing they're going to catch you again and you do it anyway.
That guy,
obviously he's got a few fucking screws when he's running for president.
Next time just be ready for the publicity.
He's going to turn it all around.
Yeah.
Wonder what,
what a guy like that eventually winds up doing.
That is an interesting point.
You can have a podcast of course.
Probably would be good at that.
Good at talking about what you could tweet right there.
That's a good promotion of his share it with your friends before they caught him
the first time,
uh,
being a freak,
they,
uh,
there was a great video of him speaking on the floor and just like really
passionate and screaming and yelling and very eloquent and very articulate and
like,
wow,
this guy is like fighting.
Same thing.
KKK letters in your past.
I mean,
why do you get one with the,
it's crazy.
I think that most people when they get to be a certain age,
they have a family and they have obligations,
mortgages,
and they have certain risks and not willing to take.
And one of the big risks is you don't want to go against the target government
and say everyone's corrupt.
Like Jesus Christ,
they'll come after you,
they'll take your house,
you know,
your,
your kids got to go to college.
So like for the guys like the Ron Paul's of the world,
you know,
it's like to get to be a certain age where they're just,
they don't give a fuck.
Like,
what are you going to do?
You're going to shoot him.
He's a fucking 85 years old or whatever he is.
You know,
he's,
he's last run for president has done now it's up to his son and his son.
Apparently he's been using cheat sheets.
What's up with that plagiarizing?
I gave the guy a lot of credit for that wonderful filibuster we did for the
fourth amendment,
got the best publicity,
the fourth amendment's gotten in so long and then you go pull that on me,
make me look like an idiot for people don't know what you're talking about.
That's apparently he had used some,
some words from some various speech that were exactly the same.
Exactly.
Is it possible that he has writers and he doesn't know?
That's what his father said.
The newsletters where that got his father in so much trouble,
but remember Rand Paul who have said Nice things about,
also has his,
one of his main advisors,
that guy who did the southern Avenger,
you know confirm?
Oh yeah.
The Guy,
one of his advisors was the southern Avenger and he wore a mask and had a
confederate flag behind him and it's like a youtube show or something.
And then when they said,
are you going to fire this guy?
He goes something like,
well,
that's all in his past,
and you just go,
what's up with this?
Why are these people all crazy?
If you talk about freedom in our constitution,
you're crazy.
That's adorable.
Yeah.
Maybe it's the southern Avenger.
Look at his fellow southern is that,
oh my God,
wait,
if that guy's on your staff and somebody,
you could honestly say,
God,
I didn't know he was a southern adventure.
Once they tell you,
don't you fire him five seconds later?
I think it's probably so,
so that that to me,
right?
There you go.
Great.
Thanks for taking my,
my pet issue of the fourth amendment and trashing it with your southern Avenger
guy.
What is a southern Avengers stance?
Maybe I'm on his team.
I don't know.
I have never watched the southern event.
You want to be.
I saw clips painting with a broad blush brush.
The confederate flag does that for you.
I don't know.
What could he possibly four.
He's confusing the shit out of me already.
Conservative,
Libertarian,
Independent.
He's done.
He's,
he's just,
he's,
he's destroyed conservative,
independent and libertarian in one tag line.
He's probably,
you know,
working for a group who's design,
who's trying to discredit all those things.
I'm surprised it doesn't have a TM at the end of it.
We'll look,
look at the logo.
It's a better logo that a lot of people have.
Yeah.
I mean,
what does he try to do?
Is this guy still acts like a wrestler?
It doesn't,
he does.
Is he still have a,
a show now?
He works for Rand Paul.
Now.
They didn't fire him.
It.
Where's Brian?
He keeps supposed to look.
All that stuff is just going to interrupt.
Oh,
he's,
he been Panish is this a temporary punishment but ran Paul still has this guy
working for,
I can't say.
I can't comment on that.
Know if the southern Avengers said anything bad.
He says speak at the same conferences.
Random Paul after neo conservative alter ego was revealed.
Hunter left a post on the,
uh,
as the Kentucky senators.
Social media.
That's the guy that's southern or avenger.
I was,
I couldn't see it.
It looks like guys look at that photo over his right shoulder for the left
shoulder.
That's disturbing.
Is that guy I have no shirt on.
There's like a bunch of people and one guy has no shirt on.
That's a gay orgy.
Southern Gay orgy.
They just said,
we just have some chicken and we're fixing to fuck.
Look at him.
The guy has no shirt on and a big chest tattoo.
What if that chest tattoo was like some fucking conservative?
You don't know what's on his back statement.
Yeah,
a big confederate flag cover of the fucking,
the roof of the Gel dude.
How come whenever you get someone who sang some important things in a halfway
decent way,
they have to come.
You know,
people say to me all the time,
when we vote all the time,
Dan,
the of course the countries on is it's based on voters voting for people.
How come?
When we get somebody who would like to change course in a direction,
most of us would like to see half of them is really fantastic and the other half
of them is so crazy.
You'd never let a person like that in a million years.
Why can't we have somebody who has some common sense and it doesn't sound like
that.
Two words,
my friends simulation theory back and diversify risk management.
Diversification tool.
Yeah.
I wonder,
you know,
I think he's hedging his bets in case white people take over the world again,
in a,
in a very dominant sort of way.
We'll have the southern Avenger on staff.
He can advise us.
You ever watched those extreme preppers shows?
Those shows were dudes or,
or fixing to the preparing for the end of the world or the banker people
stockpile and water and creating escape routes and battering rams.
They're welding to the front of their pickup truck opposite of the hoarders
because they are the borders that are doing it for a good cause,
right?
Yeah.
They believe that it's all going to come crumbling down and those,
I think that there's an mentality and the same kind of mentality that is the
type of person that wants to get in this word rebellious position of power,
rebellious position of,
you know,
railing out against the government.
They're very similar to these people that are prepping.
It's very similar to their extreme folks.
Like those are the only people that make it to the front of that crazy line.
They have to be a bit nutty.
It's not that the ideas aren't interesting to you or I,
when you look at a guy like ran Paul,
the things that he says that you agree with or his dad,
the things that he says that you agree with,
but it's to get there.
He's facing so much opposition.
There's so much bullshit along the way,
so much pressure,
so much,
so much back and forth debate.
So much frustration,
so much suppression of information.
By the time he gets to a position where the world is listening to him,
he's already broken.
He like broke every bone in his fucking soul just to get to the front of the
line.
You know what's funny though?
People say to me all the time,
you know,
can you get a staff together to do what you do so you can do better?
I want more history shows.
Can we,
can we help you do this?
And I always say the same thing.
I said,
you can't help me because I can't watch y'all and I can't keep track of it.
That's what all these people do.
You know,
what was it?
Uh,
Paul said a Ron.
Paul said,
well,
this guy who wrote,
he was doing my newsletter for me.
I was in Congress.
I didn't have time to do a newsletter.
So he did it and he wrote all this stuff and I didn't know what was happening.
That's my fear is that you're going to hire a bunch of people and then you're
gonna turn around and go,
what did you do for me?
What did you,
which we started the southern Avengers show for you.
We thought would be a good promotional vehicle for your show,
Dan.
No doubt.
Yeah,
no doubt.
I think that there's,
it's a catch 22 do you,
do you give away some of your control or do you keep it,
you know,
where you know everything's cool,
but the minute you give it away,
you got rogue people,
you know with your name running around graffitiing the side.
Banksy and Carlin,
we're here.
Some of the isolated,
the photograph pull.
This is the photograph.
It's all bunch of wrestlers.
Like a wrestler.
Yeah.
These are like old school southern wrestlers that I was probably right.
They'd probably be fucked each other.
As soon as this was over.
And this guy's got this in the,
the,
well,
he's got it framed on his wall in the background of his fucking study.
So yay.
Southern Avenger.
Yay.
Simulation theory.
And does it say he parted ways?
So are so,
so he got rid of him.
Finally,
I guess the,
the hue and cry was a little too much for a sitting senator from Kentucky to
have somebody named the southern Avenger on his staff.
Well,
he was a cogo coauthor of the 2011 book with Rand Paul,
the tea party.
Oh God.
I had maybe forgotten blanked it out.
But you're right.
It is funny that these people,
they have to be,
we can't have a fourth amendment person who's not Wa.
I mean I guess you do.
You got guys like widen and you'd all,
and some of these people,
but,
but when you get somebody who's a real lightning rod for this stuff and you
think finally,
we've been waiting for a guy like this forever.
They come with these poison pills that you just can't swallow.
Yeah,
it's an,
it's an unfortunate reality of the,
the,
the control that has been exerted on the political climate.
I mean,
the fact that the two party system exists just shows you how much power the
people that are in power.
You know,
the people that are running things,
how much they've actually been able to exert on our system.
They've locked it down to two pao,
two parties that are both often supported by the exact same corporations.
George Carlin said,
you know exactly how many people you have to bribe.
Yeah.
Bull Bill Hicks had the best.
He's like a,
he goes,
well,
I like the puppet on the left.
He's more to my liking.
Well,
the pumping on the right supports my beliefs.
Hey,
wait a minute and just one guy holding both puppets.
I mean that's really it.
That was like his description of America.
That's a really good one.
How come we don't get it then Joe,
that this is what I don't understand is that if we're going to work toward this
awareness and if we're going to get better and and more involved in enlightened,
how do we not see through that scan?
That would only be like first scan you have to see through to get to anywhere
and we don't see through that.
Well,
smart people that are on the democratic side are partially to blame.
I'm just as much as people on the conservative side.
But on the democratic side,
I've heard so many people use the term we like,
we need to get into office or we need to get more this or we,
you know,
we control the house and I'm like,
we,
we like Hollywood people.
I have had maddening conversations with people in Hollywood that used the term
we to describe the Democratic Party and I'm like,
they're not.
You do,
they're not you by a long stretch and you perpetrating this stupidity.
I understand that you work 12 hours a day and you don't have the time to
investigate this thoroughly,
but you pretending to be a smart guy and going with this team,
we need to do that and we need like how much of what they're doing are you
really fucking paying attention to?
Because this Democratic Party that's in charge right now is as Republican as it
gets when it comes to whistleblowers is Republican as it gets when it comes to
giving rights to corporations that are the same rights they used to be
attributed to individuals.
So the,
the,
all the things that we were afraid of during the Bush administration,
they're all being done to a much lower the attacks on whistleblowers to a much
larger degree.
The tax on secrecy and privacy,
much larger than has ever been exhibited before.
Those are all Republican ideas.
So when do they become democratic ideas?
I had a famous political reporter here in La when I was learning about news.
Explain it to me this way.
She goes,
I'm going to give you the secret to what the difference between the two parties
are,
and she kept it from me.
She kept it from me.
And then one day when we were going to interview Dan Quayle of all people,
believe it or not,
when he was the vice president,
she says,
okay,
the time has come to let you in on the big secret between the two parties.
So I leaned forward,
I say,
what is it?
She goes at the Republican fundraisers,
you get your wine in a glass at the democratic fundraisers.
It comes in a plastic cup.
That was it.
That was this big piece of knowledge I was waiting for.
The difference between the two parties is what they serve the wine in when you
go to their get together so deeply entrenched in money and,
and when I'm,
when I'm saying that those are democratic ideas where those are republican
ideas,
I don't mean it as then they are actually a probably good ideas.
I mean that as in the people that are on the democratic side that believe in
equality and freedom and left wing values,
they think that those ideas are only things that the republican support,
so when they're clearly being supported by the Democratic Party,
W who's who,
what's going on is up,
down is down,
up is there,
is everybody getting paid here?
Like what exactly is going on?
I think we assume these people have ideas when really they're a 20% of them do,
but I think 80% of them have the ideas as you pay them to have and also it's a
giant group of people.
In order to play politics you have to appease certain groups and you have to be
very good socially at this sort of give and take system that they've put into
place.
The cronyism system,
I mean when you look at the the,
that all these people that are lobbyists live in Virginia that's right outside
of DC and they come in and there's all this money concentrated on making things
happen there.
It's totally against the concept of we the people.
It's totally against the concept of in the interests of the individual,
the interests of the greater good of the society as a whole.
It's totally against that.
It's against it and it's transparent and it's right in everybody's face.
But I think a lot of people do get it.
Like I don't think it's an issue of lacking awareness,
at least now,
you know,
if you took 30 or so ago,
you had maybe a different story,
but pause,
sneaks on ever scenes,
you know,
confidence in government has been collapsing sharply.
Confidence in the political system.
You know,
everybody to some degree or neither hates each feel like,
ah,
it's like a rabbit.
I think that is a level of awareness of that.
What the reason is the,
okay,
then what do we do about it?
You know,
that part is the,
when we have the knowledge,
that distinct sucks,
but what can I or my neighbor or the next guy do to change this?
What steps could be taken?
And that's when people go,
don't you think more people know it sucks now than I've ever before.
And more people know why it sucks now.
And you know what the real,
and this,
this ties something else up in a boat we talked about earlier with the fracking
and the environmental damage.
Everything else.
Part of the problem we have too is we have a system here in the United States
that is,
is designed to be moderate and not radical,
which sounds fine most of the time,
but if you put off problems long enough,
the solutions that are moderate to fix them are no longer useful.
I mean,
if your house is slipping on its foundation and you get to it early,
maybe a little bit of money and a little bit of work and you can fix that.
If you put that off 10 15 years,
the solution to that problem is a lot more radical.
We have put off a lot of huge problems in this country and solving them for so
long that the solutions are so radical that we have a system that is just geared
to to tamping down that sort of radicalism.
But what does that mean if that's what it takes to fix some of the problems?
That's a very interesting point.
And then there's the idea that we're going to come up with some way in the
future to clean up all the mess that we've created and we'll fix it later.
Something will be invented.
The technology with the caraway need to do is get our backs against the wall
cause that's when America is at its best,
right?
We got our back against the wall.
I'll tell you what,
we come out swinging,
the better mouse trap will emerge and come out swinging and we're going to make
some GMO fish that eat plastic and send them bitches out there.
And then we've got all our problems.
So we're going to have the greatest population of fish and the history of the
fucking ocean because we're going to have plastic eating fish that we've made in
the lab.
They've got a steel lining to their stomach and they,
they run on fossil fuels,
forced consciousness expansion.
Maybe they will prompt the awareness by putting the hallucinogenics in the
water.
And there you go.
Well the,
a lot of people believe that they came and asteroids,
Dan Carlin,
they came from other planets simulation.
There are no other planets that chemical,
the chemical composition of mushrooms,
the four phosphoryl,
oxy and and dime methyl tryptamine or however you say it.
Wow.
Things being in the,
the phosphorus in the four positions,
the only one,
the only group of them in the entire world.
So there's no,
there's,
there's no immediate ancestors to suicide.
We're talking way over my head.
I'm talking over my head to way over my head,
Pete and some shit that I heard Terence Mckenna said,
the idea is clear on that right spores can survive in a vacuum.
The idea of pants Barea Panspermia is a,
a well accepted idea in astronomy and that idea is that life to building blocks
from life.
Water even came from other planets.
Asteroid impacts on other planets,
sent large bodies into space.
They landed on earth.
Many of them perhaps,
you know,
billions and billions and billions of years ago and actually created the ocean's
actually created a lot of life itself,
the building blocks for life.
So in a sense we are all of alien composition period,
but other things are continuing to come this way,
including spores,
which can survive in a vacuum.
And when you have large doses of siliciden mushrooms,
one of the weird things is you feel like you're communicating with something.
You feel like your and the whimsical amongst us believe that what you're
actually doing is communicating with an alien life form that have,
has come here and wants you to eat it in order to tune into it.
You know,
I actually have some thoughts that I agree with some of that.
And,
and this is coming from someone who doesn't talk about this very much,
but I've always been fascinated with how things like that had been used by
humankind throughout history as a means to open up other,
you know,
to use Huxley's term doors of perception.
Um,
it's fascinating to me when you think,
if you think that none of this stuff is,
you know,
if you think about evolutionary things,
right?
So this is all stuff that evolves.
Why the hell were hallucinogenic mushrooms?
What's the evolutionary benefit to the mushroom itself?
To have that.
Is it supposed to ward off birds from eating it because they get a bad trip?
If they do,
I find it fascinating.
How much of a role,
you know,
we did a podcast once about the,
the,
the hidden side of intoxication in history.
Well I think you could make a very good case that hallucinogenics of all kinds
have probably played huge roles in history that we don't even know about,
especially with tribal peoples who have played a huge role.
I mean,
why did the Germans decided to migrate into Roman territory?
It just,
this time will they have sorcerers and which doctors as part of their culture
who lose used hallucinogenics who knows that they didn't go to the chiefs in
there and say,
you remember that thing I told you we have to do?
I was just told now's the right time.
Move into that Roman territory and all history is different.
I mean that's the side of history.
We're never going to get,
be interesting to find out how much of history has been determined by things
like that.
The episode,
by the way,
it was hilarious.
I remember
the problem is is that you can't know,
so the whole thing is speculative,
but you can say,
well,
Napoleon had opium the night before Waterloo and he slept late and he was
sluggish.
How much did that impact history?
And some you've got to go,
you've got to the little teeny pieces
of the jigsaw puzzle,
you know about that construct.
A totally fictional narrative that might be true.
Well,
there's one thing that's undeniable.
People love altering their consciousness.
Yes,
it's true.
They love it so much that in this day and age we have partnership for a drug
free America and they're finding against the trend,
right?
Who not only that are funded initially by alcohol and tobacco companies now
mostly by pharmaceutical muscletech of course,
which is so rich and so delicious.
I,
the way I described it,
I go that having pharmaceutical companies and allowing them to do literally
commercials against marijuana is like hookers making commercials against
strippers.
Right?
That's,
it's literally,
it's like the most ridiculous things.
It is.
The idea behind it is,
you know,
it's so preposterous,
but we have,
we still have a method and as long as you give people a method,
if they'll accept a certain amount of restrictions,
as long as the method is good and the method is very good,
the alcohol method is great for most sacks.
If prohibition,
I hadn't been repealed,
I mean,
think about how interesting a world we might live in today had that stayed the
law of the land.
I don't think it can.
I don't think you can have no options for people to,
well,
the old,
one thing that's interesting is during prohibition,
marijuana was legal.
Marijuana wasn't legal until after prohibition.
The Henry Anslinger and all those pet.
Yeah,
Harry Anslinger and I'm William Randolph Hearst.
They actually did,
they originally done it.
They really originally did it to try to suppress hemp as a commodity because you
got so much more than you got out of threes.
And if you're in the business of making paper business,
the logging industry,
and that's also a perfect example of the difference between controlling
information.
Back then and today,
they were able to sell this idea that there's a new drug that was forcing
Mexicans and blacks to wait,
rape white women and they even name this drug marijuana,
which is a name for a Mexican slang term for a while tobacco had nothing to do
with cannabis.
You know what does blow me away though?
It blows me away.
I can understand you making the case that this has to be illegal.
Whatever we're talking,
this has to be legal because it's so dangerous and we know it so dangerous.
What I don't understand is that we basically have a policy in this country that
there will be no new intoxicants.
If something is invented in a bath tub tomorrow that doesn't hurt anybody,
that has no hangovers,
that nobody gets in car.
We're going to ban it the day after tomorrow on general principles and that's
what I don't understand.
What is that?
There are beneficial drugs that they have to attribute to diseases in order to
get them pass through there.
Like there's a thing called provigil and provigil is this smart drug that all of
these is silicon valley on
breast.
Some pretty impressive stuff.
Provigils pretty wild and it gives you this buzz but it doesn't give you a
caffeine.
He buzz,
it's not like a heart rate thing.
It gives you this clarity thing.
It's a very strange sort of intoxicant or of,
it's sort of a pharmaceutical drug rather.
But they,
they couldn't just sell it as a performance enhancing drug,
so they had to sell it as some sort of a response to a disease.
So they came up with narcolepsy.
It's like,
yeah,
narcolepsy.
I've heard about,
but it was originally created in order to like,
it was created to benefit consciousness,
but you can't do that.
You can't have a drug that just a drug that makes you smarter.
You literally can't you,
there has to be something wrong with your fucking brain so they have to come up
with something.
Right.
That's a weird rut.
But here's the weird thing.
If that's how it has to be.
Why don't they all go back and then find things,
you know?
Couldn't you sell the old drugs that way?
Yeah,
I guess they are kind of,
I mean if you think about it,
that's what the whole medical marijuana kind of thing could be construed as if
you wanted to.
Well,
we found a new way to market this thing.
It's a solution to a problem.
Yeah.
Well,
medical marijuana is the reason why they're,
that's the backdoor that I think we all understand that even if we think that
there are,
and I do think there are medical uses for this stuff,
there's no question that it has been used as a backdoor to sort of open the door
to what would not have been possible without it.
Also all genius.
I'm just throwing it out there.
Getting people in government addicted to the money and the revenue that it
brings us.
True legal.
That's church.
You don't get at all.
If it's illegal,
the,
the money still goes into the economy and that's,
that's been really documented in British Columbia that the economy is very
dependent.
Even though it's illegal,
but the taxes that you would get from selling it,
the government actually is what loses out on marijuana being illegal.
The government loses out because they not getting any of the tax money from it
being sold to one of the things we create and do well in this country too.
You'd think they'd be hard to sort of safeguard the few things we do well and
producing in this guy.
They're just starting to now pass laws and no,
and on it we sell hemp protein powder,
but we have to buy or hemp protein powder in Canada.
It's legal to possess.
It's legal to sell.
It's not legal to grow.
That is so asinine because you're not even talking about a psychoactive plan.
You're talking about the male version of the cannabis plant.
It's roped the very,
yeah,
the different variations.
The the,
the cousins of the cannabis plant,
there's,
there's more than one different type of hemp,
but all of them,
what they all have in la and they share in common is the amount of THC in them
is insanely small.
So what you're getting out of it is just a textile you're getting,
you're getting close,
you're getting oil,
you're getting food that you can eat and we can't even grow it in America.
We're buying it in bulk from Canada and then we sell it.
We try to buy the best stuff that we could possibly find and it's really
difficult like because unless you can grow it yourself like it's hard to quality
control.
You have to,
you have to like really search out these farms that are in another country that
are growing this shit and it's so stupid,
so they're just starting to pass laws that are allowing farmers to grow it.
In America.
California's recently passed it.
They're trying to pass it in other states.
I believe they passed it in Colorado and I believe they passed it in Washington
state because those are the two places where they've made it legal to consume
for adults.
I sewed the,
one of the best documentaries I've seen on these,
there's this documentary called standing silent nation,
which is what happened a few years ago on the Pine Ridge reservation surveys.
Start with for those who are Italian accent impaired,
he said standing silent nature nation nation.
So I understood him.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Standing silent nation.
That was really cool.
It showed what happened on Pine Ridge,
which was,
you know,
one of the poorest reservations in the United States where prospects for
economic growth are really deem.
And so what these guys did,
they figure,
you know,
we are somewhat of a sovereign entity because that's our reservation sat right
there in this weird limbo and they figure,
okay,
we can plant industrial hamper,
will cultivate it,
will do this whole thing.
And you see the progression through drew command three of the viciousness with
which the da goes after them to just stamp it out.
And you see the facts that you are listening right now.
You know the THC aspect and the fact that this is not a drag.
You know,
we're not talking about a drug.
You're not talking about marijuana as a,
you know,
even money when I was there [inaudible] but let's,
that's a whole different stories.
There are none of the THC that you find in that.
It's the same plant,
but he's like marijuana without the stuff that gets you high and you use it for
Emilio and seeing so that as you say,
it's legal to own the products in the United States,
but it's not legal to grow it where we can actually make it a product in the
United States and there's no argument for it.
It just makes no sense.
It's a t,
it's a,
it's a commodity.
It's a commodity that's being banned because of a close association with an
intoxicated intoxicated.
By the way,
it's the safest known to man one,
not that has massive amounts of medical benefits documented for sure for real
noncontroversial medical benefits and it's illegal.
I've never understood why we don't have,
you know,
cause I always thought one of the arguments that screwed up kids the most was to
put marijuana on this list of terrible drugs because then they,
when they try the marijuana,
they think you're lying about the heroin.
Right.
I always thought that there ought to be a checklist that the government used to
decide if something should be legal or illegal.
You know,
a hundred questions.
How addictive is it likely to be,
you know,
how dangerous,
how many of you blah blah,
blah.
And then if you pass or fail,
you know you pass,
it's legal.
If you fit that,
that also would be used if you invent some new bathtub drug tomorrow.
Okay,
well let's run it down the checklist.
Right.
And then you could say to the people,
well look,
I mean here's how it's scored in the checklist and I think the damage to that
would be,
cause alcohol might not score very highly on that.
But certainly I don't think that there's any way marijuana doesn't score better
than most of the intoxicants that are out there today.
And I think,
I guess what I'm saying is I think it would help me in raising my own children
and keeping them off these harder drugs to be able to have a decent argument.
There's a good reason this heroin isn't in general use kids.
It'll really hurt you.
Trust me.
It wouldn't be illegal if it wouldn't really hurt.
Well what's mind boggling is that that's not even scheduled one here.
I know cause medical use census,
right?
Heroin is scheduled scheduled to schedule one,
the most dangerous of all drugs.
Marijuana is in that.
I remember that a running salt that Ronald Reagan in the 80s,
marijuana is the most dangerous drug in America.
That was a great speech.
How could you hold that face?
It's hilarious.
You know,
they found that cone snail venom,
um,
there they can make a drug out of cone snail venom that it's
a hundred times more potent than any existing pain medication and it's
completely non addictive.
So it works a hundred times better than all of the oxycontins and all that other
shit.
And it's not addictive.
Why listen to this,
the message this evening is not my message,
but hours.
Despite our best efforts,
shortage of marijuana,
I now being reported from the early,
this is not,
this is,
this is a parody parody.
You fail,
fail hard,
dude.
So what I have to say to my mythical producer all the time,
fail.
How dare you?
Um,
yeah,
it,
it becomes an insult and it becomes one more piece of evidence that we're
getting fucked.
And it's,
it's bad to have that out there if you want to run a government.
Right.
Because it fuels the resistance.
It fuels people's,
it turns the citizens into the enemy.
That's what it does.
There's millions and millions of fucking schedule one criminals in this country,
clenching guy who run the stop sign at Walmart into the bad guy.
Well,
he didn't even have any marijuana on,
and that's the part I like.
But marijuana was the Rick,
do you know that?
That's what they suspected him of having.
Yeah.
So here's the thing.
So I'm walking,
I'm in my car and I've got some marijuana I want to smoke later,
but I'm afraid if it's in my car,
you'll find it.
So I shove it up my rear end so that I can smoke it later.
I did.
The whole thing is so insane.
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
We're living in a simulation.
So real and wiener,
he's not real wieners showing his wiener come on.
None of it's real.
It's not real.
We're all mad.
We're mad as a hatter and we're just alone by herself somewhere linked up to
some computer trying to pretend at this fucking simulated society we pieced
together.
Makes it very interested to hear what they're writing on Rogan's message board
about this wide variety of interesting topics.
Oh,
what do you mean?
He told us grief.
I get right back to it.
Let me see what he does here.
Savages.
Well,
we're a new world order mouthpiece here at the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
I don't know if you know that.
I became a new world order mouthpiece once a,
I started doing that.
Joe Rogan questions everything.
Oh,
of course.
It wasn't really willing to question everything.
I thought.
I thought the eye rolls that you did were absolutely artistic in some of those
things very much.
Well,
some,
it got to a certain point where I was like,
you know what?
I can't do this anymore.
I can't keep talking to liars,
you know,
and and pretending that we're putting together a TV show.
When I'm talking to a guy who told me he saw bulletproof wolf that popped out of
a,
a vortex of missed or somebody told you that?
Yeah,
it's true.
By the way.
Also told me he saw a Ufo,
sees them on a regular basis and went and found bigfoot the very first time we
went looking for it.
I was like,
Oh cry money.
Like what am I doing with my life?
This is like we're so far off of the reality road that I don't,
I'm never going to find my way back.
I just talk to it is pretty hard to maintain the straight face thing.
It's not worth it.
It is a certain point in time you're like,
oh this is just a broken idea.
These are,
this is a person with a,
they're chasing
down thoughts that are bad and they don't stop chasing them down and they're
reasonably intelligent so they can argue the way around these things.
When confronted and Michael Shermer had a quote about that,
about really smart people who believe in really dump things cause they're smart
enough to argue it.
And I think that's,
that's the case with a lot of these folks and the flaw in the thinking is so
obvious.
So when I didn't believe in chem trails that every fucking airplane that you see
a contrail that's persistent is the government spraying us with evil chemicals.
All of a sudden people were like,
you're a fucking mouthpiece.
The new world.
I told you I got that too though for questioning the Hastings thing and yeah,
but you know,
you're going to get that,
get it all.
But then when you have a warped view that's nuanced when you went some wonderful
word.
Yes.
Thank you.
By the way,
for [inaudible] now to public on [inaudible].
Got It.
Everybody got it.
But yeah,
the um,
because the fact is like the reviews you get or the feed bag of that joy's got
ton about this stuff to me is not surprising because anytime you have a position
that's not stereotypical or you're not clearly in one camp,
150% where is the Oh as well did it or no,
that's total bullshit.
How can you believe that?
Or you know about anything,
right?
When you start asking questions that poke holes in one line of thinking,
but then at the same time when people started feeling reassured that Oh Dan you
are on this side.
Then you start saying well kind of by weight the sack him.
Cause there was one,
there was something gear that's problematic here and you're just keeping an open
mind,
right?
It doesn't mean that you can commit to an idea.
It doesn't mean that you are flip flopping yard.
Just considering the pros and cons and some time is not that black and white.
It drives people crazy
because the media doesn't want you to do that.
And he did it because they used to tell me on the radio,
a listener has to know where you stand on every issue within three minutes of
turning you on.
And I said,
that's a cartoon character or a real person.
And it's the same thing where,
um,
I had just done a show recently where we were talking about,
go ahead and wrap this up.
The point is it that that whole idea that,
that,
that nuance is a bad thing.
Somebody called me,
I'm being called a moderate and a realist more and more today,
which is coming from like tin foil,
hat,
crazy radical territory and I haven't changed my views at all in 20 years.
Well,
a couple things,
but basically it means that society,
like you said,
has started to pick up on things and has moved in a direction.
I used to say to people,
the NSA spying on everyone and they said,
no,
they're not.
You're crazy.
Get your tinfoil hat out.
Now I say the NSA spying on everyone and they go,
I know.
So society is just sort of moved in a different direction and nuance.
That's what society is missing today.
Gray areas.
I've been called a conspiracy theory or with good reason for theorists for a
long time about a lot of different subjects,
but I've always found that really odd that the idea that people haven't
conspired on things is,
is so attractive to people.
Right?
Like people want to be able to debunk things just as willingly as other people
want to find conspiracy and things.
And there's some things that are,
are not debunk bull.
There's some realities he bankable.
Yeah.
Some realities like the reality of the fucking central bank,
the reality of the realities of the influence of the Bilderberg group,
the the out,
the realities of the influence of corporations and special interest groups and
lobbyists,
those are real,
those are real things.
So if those exist,
those are probably some of the biggest conspiracies the entire world has ever
known,
and they're right in front of your fat fucking face.
Okay.
Look at the reality of money today and what monies controlling whether or not
this gas land documentary is 100% correct,
even if it's 50% correct.
That 50% is fucking terrifying.
And every one of those examples that they showed that if those were the only
examples,
and I don't think they are,
we're doing something crazy and it's all being done because of money.
We're ruining this world forever.
Whether it's the ocean patch that's bigger than Texas,
it's all plastic that's floating out there and choking birds and whales and
whale was just be a beached whale.
Just died.
His stomach was filled with plastic.
I mean we,
what we are doing for real that we're doing bad is fucking insane.
Yup.
So anybody who's not willing to look at the other possibilities like,
man,
you're rigid view of the world is fucking your head up.
There's some weirdness of foot simulation theory,
gun,
short term gain baby.
That way I wasn't doing any good for me.
Lee Harvey Oswald acted alone.
Case closed.
I say case closed.
Well listen,
I think we could do this at the end of the time,
the end of today,
but we were not going to.
This is that we're going to wrap this up,
but we could fucking do this again.
God Damn it,
Dan Carlin,
you don't go below.
Thank you for coming up with this idea.
This is mister bow,
Ellie's ideas.
I came up with it without telling either of you.
I felt both of you.
There was a mind meld and a,
if anybody wants to listen to Daniela [inaudible] podcast,
it is the drunk and Taoist.
It's available on everything,
right?
Itunes and is it on Stitcher as well?
Yep.
Stitch stitcher and of course Dan Carlin is not one but two fucking podcast.
Jesus Christ as if you had enough free time to absorb them all.
One is hardcore history,
which is absolutely sensational.
The other one is DC common sense,
a little mediocre,
I guess.
They're bulk,
awesome lies and you can catch them on iTunes.
He gives away the first 50 for free.
He's just to get you hooked and then the rest of them you get by prescription
prescription.
I shouldn't say prescription because you can learn to fucking,
it's good for your brain subscription,
but they are fucking worth it there.
God Damn books,
their audio books,
their lessons on life and the history of this wacky ass country of so get them
bitches.
Go get 'em,
go go after it.
And a,
I want to thank our sponsors for sponsoring this podcast.
Specifically Carbonite,
Carbonite,
the awesome backup program.
Use The code word J R E for a free trial,
no credit card required.
Thanks also to stamps.com use the Promo Code j r e and get a $110 bonus offer.
Thanks also to onnit.com that's o n n I t.
Use the code name,
Rogan.
Save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right,
we love the fuck out of you guys.
We have a great week next week,
including I got an astronaut coming in,
fuckers.
I got that guy commander.
What it or he,
uh,
was the dude who,
let me find this,
uh,
this email before we wrap this up because I have to be dirt or the dirt or hold
on a second.
Oh boy isn't,
this is a fucking great way to end an awesome podcast.
Let me searching through my fucking email.
Like a moron,
Colonel Chris Hatfield.
Chris Hadfield was a,
he was up in the space station until recently,
the Canadian astronaut that was in the news.
He'll be here on Monday.
Um,
and uh,
we also have,
uh,
next week we have Graham Hancock is coming in on Wednesday,
should be fantastic.
And Ana Kasparian,
uh,
from the young Turks.
She will be here on Tuesday.
So it's a fun filled week.
You freaks.
And,
uh,
I will see you guys Saturday night in Edmonton at the River Creek casino with
the lovely and talented Sam Tripoli.
And uh,
thank you.
Thank you to Dan Carlin.
Thank you to Danieli.
Bolelli it was a beautiful time had by all,
we love the fuck.
How do people see as soon.